Great news. The federal EV rebate is back. Eligible customers get up to $5,000 with the federal EVAP rebate on select 2027 volt and 2026 Equinox EV models. Visit your local Chevrolet dealer today for more details. Oh, I'd love to enter politics. I will one day. I'd adore to be Prime Minister. And yes, I believe very strongly in fascism. The only way we can see. speed up the sort of liberalism that's hanging foul in the air at the moment, is to speed up the progress of a right wing, totally dictatorial tyranny, and get it over as fast as possible. People have always responded with greater efficiency under a regimental leadership. A liberal wastes time saying,
好消息。联邦电动汽车退税回归了。符合条件的客户购买指定的2027款Volt和2026款Equinox电动车型，可获得最高5000美元的联邦EVAP退税。详情请咨询当地雪佛兰经销商。哦，我非常想进入政界。总有一天我会的。我非常渴望成为首相。是的，我非常坚定地信仰法西斯主义。我们能看到的唯一出路，就是加速目前空气中弥漫的那种自由主义，加速右翼、完全独裁的暴政进程，并尽快结束这一切。在军事化领导下，人们总是能以更高的效率做出反应。自由主义者只会浪费时间说，
well now, what ideas have you got? Show them what to do for God's sake. If you don't, nothing will get done. I can't stand people, just hang. about. Television is the most successful fascist, needless to say. Rock stars are fascists too. Adolf Hitler was one of the first rock stars. Look at some of his films and see how he moved. I think he was quite as good as Jagger. It's astounding. And boy, when he hit that stage, he worked an audience. Good God! He was no politician. He was a media artist himself. So that was the rock star David Bowie interviewed in Playboy in September 1976. And the big question, what's going on there?
好吧，你有什么想法？看在上帝的份上，告诉他们该怎么做。如果你不这样做，什么也做不成。我受不了那些只会闲逛的人。不用说，电视是最成功的法西斯主义者。摇滚明星也是法西斯主义者。阿道夫·希特勒是第一批摇滚明星之一。看看他的一些电影，看看他是如何行动的。我觉得他一点也不比贾格尔差。这太令人震惊了。天哪，当他登上舞台时，他调动观众的能力太强了。天哪！他根本不是政治家。他自己就是一位媒体艺术家。以上就是1976年9月《花花公子》杂志采访摇滚明星大卫·鲍伊的内容。那么大问题来了，这到底是怎么回事？
Did he really mean it? Was he playing a part, perhaps, as he loved to do in the 1970s, the decade of Ziggy Stardust and Aladdin's sane? And of course, the part he's playing here is the thin white Duke, who Bowie described as a very Aryan fascist type. Or was he just completely off his head on Coke and speed? So many questions, Dominic. But whatever the explanation, the thing is that he was saying quite a lot of things like that in 1975 and 1976.
他是认真的吗？也许他只是在扮演一个角色，就像他喜欢在20世纪70年代——那个属于“齐格·星尘”和“理智的阿拉丁”的十年——所做的那样？当然，他在这里扮演的角色是“瘦白公爵”，鲍伊将其描述为一种非常雅利安式的法西斯类型。还是说他当时只是因为可卡因和安非他命而神志不清？多米尼克，问题太多了。但无论如何解释，事实是他在1975年和1976年确实说了不少类似的话。
So here he is being interviewed by the NME in October 1975, where he said, What Britain needs is an extreme right front to come up and sweep everything off its feet and tidy everything up. He said the coming of the far right would do something positive at least to cause a commotion in people. and they'll either accept dictatorship or get rid of it. In April 1976, he was telling a press conference that Britain could benefit from a fascist leader. And then in May 1976, so the following month, came the most notorious incident of all when he turned up at Victoria Station in, I think, an open-top Mercedes and greeted fans with what was alleged at the time to be a Nazi salute and which Bowie, Elon Musk style, subsequently said had just been a wave. And then a few weeks later, he gives it the interview that I've just cited.
这是他在1975年10月接受《新音乐快递》（NME）采访时的言论，他说：“英国需要一个极右翼阵线站出来，横扫一切，清理一切。”他说，极右翼的到来至少会产生积极的影响，引起人们的骚动，他们要么接受独裁，要么摆脱它。1976年4月，他在新闻发布会上表示，英国可以从法西斯领导人身上获益。接着在1976年5月，也就是接下来的一个月，发生了最臭名昭著的事件：他乘坐一辆敞篷奔驰车（我想是这样）出现在维多利亚车站，并以当时被指控为纳粹礼的手势向粉丝致意，而鲍伊后来以埃隆·马斯克式的口吻称那只是在挥手。几周后，他接受了刚才我引用的那次采访。
So you can fall down a massive rabbit hole in the internet, looking into all this, because Bowie fans will often say he was just waving, and he's been very hard done by the press photographers. On the other hand, as you say, there are a lot of such incidents in 1975 and 1976, and it's quite an odd part to choose to play. However, it's a very suggestive part, because this is a period in British history, the mid-1970s, when there's an awful lot of talk about Britain as the new Weimar Germany, about the ravages of inflation, about the rise
所以你可能会在互联网上陷入一个巨大的兔子洞，深入研究这一切，因为鲍伊的粉丝通常会说他只是在挥手，而且他受到了新闻摄影师的不公正对待。另一方面，正如你所说，1975年和1976年确实发生了许多此类事件，而且选择扮演这样一个角色确实非常奇怪。然而，这是一个非常有暗示性的角色，因为这是英国历史上的一个时期，即70年代中期，当时关于英国是“新魏玛德国”、关于通货膨胀的破坏、关于崛起的讨论非常多。
of political extremism, the decay of the centre, and about the possibility, even the probability that Britain will slide into some sort of authoritarianism. And the thing is, Dominic, isn't it, that the genius of Bowie is that he is superb at his chameleon-esque qualities, at finding character. who do reflect the zeitgeist. You absolutely, right? He does reflect the zeitgeist. And I think a little bit like
政治极端主义、中间派的衰落，以及英国滑向某种威权主义的可能性，甚至是概率。多米尼克，关键在于，鲍伊的天才之处在于他极其擅长变色龙般的特质，擅长寻找那些反映时代精神的角色。你说得完全对，他确实反映了时代精神。我觉得有点像
the Fulte Towers rant that you did last week, it's a nice window into the sort of nightmares of the British imagination in the mid-70s. I mean, the thing about Hitler being better than Jagger. Yes, sort of bonkers. All right, so last week we talked about the revolution on the right when Margaret Thatcher became leader of the Tory Party. We talked about the inertia and the shabbiness
你上周做的关于《弗尔蒂旅馆》的咆哮，这是窥视70年代中期英国人想象中噩梦的一扇窗口。我是说，关于希特勒比贾格尔更厉害的说法。是的，有点疯狂。好吧，上周我们谈到了玛格丽特·撒切尔成为保守党领袖时的右翼革命。我们谈到了哈罗德·威尔逊政府的惰性和破败，
of the Harold Wilson government and the popular vote to stay in Europe in Britain's first. referendum. And all of this, of course, was against this very bleak backdrop, which obviously informs David Bowie's persona. This is Britain heading towards what looks like a financial meltdown, so very dependent on massive borrowing. The government is handing out all these huge pay deals, 30% here, 31% there, to the trade unions. The Wilson government seems utterly becalmed and inflation is heading through the roof. And actually, before we get back into the politics
以及英国首次公投中支持留在欧洲的民意。当然，所有这些都是在非常凄凉的背景下进行的，这显然影响了大卫·鲍伊的人格。当时的英国正走向看起来像是金融崩溃的局面，非常依赖大规模借贷。政府向工会发放了所有这些巨额薪酬协议，这里30%，那里31%。威尔逊政府似乎完全陷入了停滞，通货膨胀正在飙升。事实上，在我们回到政治话题之前，
of it, let's just dwell on the culture for a second. So Tom, I know you're writing about the beetles at the moment, aren't you? So, swinging London and the, the, the, the, the, the zany, madcap mood of the 1960s is very much nutty fun. It's very much on your mind. But in the 1970s, so 10 years on, right, we're 10 years on from the first articles and the international press that were celebrating swinging London, you know, Carnaby Street and mini, mini skirts, dolly birds, the sun is shining, all this. It's now 1975, the most popular musical act. This is a sign of how music has evolved since those innocent days is the Bay City Rollers. And among the number one singles of the year are bangers by the likes of Tully Savalas.
让我们先谈谈文化。汤姆，我知道你现在正在写关于披头士乐队的文章，对吧？所以，摇摆伦敦以及20世纪60年代那种古怪、疯狂的情绪非常有趣。这很让你挂心。但在70年代，也就是10年后，对吧，距离国际媒体庆祝摇摆伦敦、卡纳比街、迷你裙、时髦女郎、阳光明媚等报道已经过去10年了。现在是1975年，最受欢迎的音乐表演是海湾城滚轴乐队，这标志着音乐自那些纯真年代以来的演变。而当年的冠军单曲中，还有像特利·萨瓦拉斯这样的歌手带来的热门歌曲。
Cojack. Billy Connolly. Amusing Scottish comedian. Windsor Davis. Played a sergeant major in a now cancelled BBC sitcom about the British in India. I mean, it's insane that he had a number one single. And a great friend of yours, actually, Rod Stewart. So you celebrated Rod Stewart's birthday last year with him, didn't you?
《科杰克》。比利·康诺利，有趣的苏格兰喜剧演员。温莎·戴维斯，在一部现已被取消的关于英国人在印度的BBC情景喜剧中饰演军士长。我的意思是，他竟然有一首冠军单曲，这太疯狂了。还有你的好朋友，罗德·斯图尔特。你去年和他一起庆祝了罗德·斯图尔特的生日，不是吗？
But I'm not going to go into any more details about that. Yeah, that's a story for a bonus episode. Now, among the younger generation of musicians who are coming through, the mood is very, very dark. So this is the bassist and co-vocalist of the stranglers, Jean-Jacques Bernel, who actually had a history degree. Bernel was interviewed in 1975, and he said, everyone is paranoid, there's decay everywhere. We've always lived with the assumption that things were getting better and better,
但我不会再深入讨论那个细节了。是的，那是额外剧集的故事。现在，在涌现出的年轻一代音乐家中，情绪非常、非常阴暗。这是“扼杀者”乐队的贝斯手兼联合主唱让-雅克·伯内尔，他实际上拥有历史学位。伯内尔在1975年接受采访时说，每个人都偏执，到处都在腐烂。我们一直生活在一种假设中，即事情会越来越好，
progress all the time. And suddenly it's like you hear every day there's a crisis, financial crisis, things being laid off, people not working. Everything is coming to a grinding halt. No more heroes, Dominic. No more heroes, exactly. This is the environment that gives rise to punk, which is beginning to stir in 1975. So we ended last time with the referendum, which was in June. A few weeks later, in August, probably the 23rd, a teenage dropout, very skinny and emaciated with this kind of shock of spiky dyed green hair, goes to a pub on the Kings Road in Chelsea to audition for a new band
一直在进步。突然之间，就像你每天听到的那样，到处都是危机，金融危机，裁员，人们失业。一切都陷入了停滞。没有英雄了，多米尼克。没有英雄了，没错。这就是孕育朋克的环境，它在1975年开始萌芽。所以我们上次以6月份的公投结束。几周后，在8月，大概是23日，一个十几岁的辍学生，非常瘦弱，留着那种竖起的染绿头发，去了切尔西国王路的一家酒吧，为一支新乐队试镜，
that's been founded by a local boutique owner and the boy's name is John Leiden and the band's name is the sex pistols. So that was the 23rd of August. Five days later on the 28th of August, this is a good window, I think, into the sort of the flavor of the time. A bomb goes off outside selfridges
这支乐队是由当地一家精品店老板创立的，那个男孩的名字叫约翰·莱顿，乐队的名字叫性手枪。那是8月23日。五天后的8月28日，我认为这是一个很好的窗口，可以了解当时的风气。一枚炸弹在塞尔福里奇百货公司外爆炸，
on Oxford streets and it injures seven people. The day after that, the 29th, another bomb goes off on Kensington Church Street, and it killed the bomb disposal officer who'd been sent to deal with it instantly. The 5th of September, there was a bomb at the Hilton on Park Lane that killed two people injured 63. On the 9th of October, a bomb went off outside Green Park tube station on Piccadilly, killed one man and injured 20, some of them children on a night out. And in the rest of October and November, 1975, there are bombs in the West End every few days. And these are the work of a provisional IRA cell
在牛津街，炸伤了七个人。第二天，即29日，另一枚炸弹在肯辛顿教堂街爆炸，当场炸死了被派去处理它的拆弹警官。9月5日，公园巷的希尔顿酒店发生炸弹袭击，造成两人死亡，63人受伤。10月9日，皮卡迪利大街的绿园地铁站外发生炸弹爆炸，造成一人死亡，20人受伤，其中一些是外出游玩的孩子。在1975年10月和11月的其余时间里，西区每隔几天就会发生炸弹袭击。这些都是临时爱尔兰共和军小组的杰作，
who were later captured, captured in December in Bulcom Street near Marleybone. So that's why they're called the Bulcombe Street Gang. And there are seven more bomb attacks in London in 1976. They've slightly been forgotten, I think, now. People don't really talk about these. But, I mean, there's basically a bomb every few days in the West End in late 1975 and 1976.
他们后来在12月于马里波恩附近的巴尔科姆街被捕。所以他们被称为“巴尔科姆街团伙”。1976年伦敦又发生了七起炸弹袭击。我想现在人们已经稍微忘记了这些。人们并不真正谈论这些。但是，基本上在1975年底和1976年，西区每隔几天就会有一枚炸弹。
And then, of course, on top of all that, every day when you opened your newspaper at the breakfast table as people still did in the 70s you would read reports of some new shooting or some new atrocity in Northern Ireland
当然，最重要的是，在70年代，当你每天在早餐桌上打开报纸时，你都会读到关于北爱尔兰发生新的枪击事件或新的暴行的报道。
so maybe 500 people kill more than 500 actually in the course of 1975 and 1976 and actually some of the worst incidents that the troubles happened in those years So the sense of a country disintegrating into violence completely the whole time
所以可能在1975年和1976年期间，有超过500人死亡，实际上是超过500人，而且“动乱”中一些最严重的事件就发生在那些年。所以，整个国家一直处于陷入暴力的解体感中。
and I think the link between that and the popular culture I mean it's obvious on the one hand people want very escapist popular culture or they want nostalgia, so they're looking back to the war, as we were talking about last week. But on the other hand, if you're young, there is a sense of kind of violence in the air, I think, and of a sort of a disintegration and whatnot, which obviously plays a part in the genesis of punk music.
我认为这与流行文化之间的联系，一方面很明显，人们想要非常逃避现实的流行文化，或者他们想要怀旧，所以他们回顾战争，就像我们上周谈到的那样。但另一方面，如果你年轻，我认为空气中有一种暴力感，有一种解体感等等，这显然在朋克音乐的起源中发挥了作用。
So that's the background, but let's get back to the politics. So what is the Prime Minister been doing? Harold Wilson has been on holiday that August. After the referendum was over, he went off to, of course, inevitably, the silly aisles to wear his very short shorts. His chief policy advisor Bernard Donahue has been on holiday in France. When Donahue gets back, he writes this unbelievably searing diary entry about the state of the nation. He says, I've been in France, I've come home, and I've been forced to realise that this nation is in sad decline. And he says, because Harold is in the silly aisles, he just doesn't get it.
这就是背景，但让我们回到政治上来。那么首相在做什么？哈罗德·威尔逊那个八月一直在度假。公投结束后，他当然不可避免地去了锡利群岛，穿着他那条非常短的短裤。他的首席政策顾问伯纳德·多纳休一直在法国度假。当多纳休回来时，他写了一篇关于国家状况的令人难以置信的尖锐日记。他说：“我在法国，我回家了，我被迫意识到这个国家正在悲哀地衰落。”他说，因为哈罗德在锡利群岛，他根本不明白。
He's completely isolated from the remorseless relative decline of this country. And then this extraordinary passage. Britain is a miserable sight A society of failures Full of apathy Aroused only by envy At the success of others Meanness has replaced generosity
他完全与这个国家无情的相对衰落隔绝了。然后是这段非凡的段落。英国是一个悲惨的景象，一个充满冷漠的失败者社会，只有嫉妒他人的成功才能被激起，卑鄙取代了慷慨。
Envy has replaced endeavour Malice is the most common motivation This is the social personality Of a loser Fascism could breed In this unhealthy climate When he says That its society arrives
嫉妒取代了努力，恶意是最常见的动机。这就是失败者的社会人格。在这种不健康的氛围中，法西斯主义可能会滋生。当他说那个社会到来时，
Only by envy at the success of others I mean that's quite a right wing Perspective isn't it The politics of envy and all of that Yeah completely And this is the result, I think, of having been in Downing Street and having, you know, Donahue has been there all the time when the different union leaders have come in to demand a particular deal for their members. And they would literally say, I mean, there was some fantastic sort of accounts. They would say, I'm the leader of the railwayman.
只有嫉妒他人的成功，我的意思是这是一种非常右翼的观点，不是吗？嫉妒的政治等等。是的，完全是。我认为这是在唐宁街工作的结果，你知道，多纳休一直都在那里，当不同的工会领导人进来要求为他们的成员提供特定的协议时。他们会直截了当地说，我的意思是，有一些非常棒的叙述。他们会说，我是铁路工人的领袖。
I notice the postman got 30%. I have to go back to my, you know, my members and say that I've got better than the postman. Yeah, this is how it is. And this sort of competition, I think a lot of Labour Ministers found this incredibly depressing, that they're basically being forced into this constant game of giving out bigger and bigger deals. So you think he's specifically thinking about union leaders when he says that? I don't know that he's necessarily specifically thinking about it, but I think there's a general sense of mean spiritedness in politics at this point and in public life and a sense of kind of national solidarity breaking down. And also, Dominic, those awful enormous kippa ties and the brown suits and the very thick glasses. frames. I mean, it's really depressing. Do they have those in France? I don't think so.
我注意到邮递员得到了30%。我必须回去告诉我的成员，我得到的比邮递员多。是的，情况就是这样。这种竞争，我认为很多工党部长发现这令人难以置信地沮丧，他们基本上被迫陷入这种不断给予更大、更大协议的游戏中。所以你认为他在说这话时特别想到了工会领导人？我不知道他是否一定特别想到了这一点，但我认为此时政治和公共生活中有一种普遍的卑劣感，以及一种国家团结正在瓦解的感觉。还有，多米尼克，那些可怕的巨大领带、棕色西装和非常厚的眼镜框。我的意思是，这真的很令人沮丧。法国有这些吗？我不这么认为。
No, I think they do actually. I think there's some terrible fashions in France. I mean, it's important to remember that through all this period these people are eating 1970s food. So imagine how depressing that is. Yeah, Black Forest Gatto. Well, they're eating Black Forest Gatto, but also drinking enormous quantities, presumably of blue none. And Black Tower, what else would they be drinking, sort of wine in elaborate bottles with a kind of lattice on the outside? However, on the positive side, as you remind us in your wonderful books, children do have space hoppers. So it's not all bad. They do have spacehoppers. Yeah, and rally chopper bikes. So every we've literally ticked every box, every 70's box. So anyway, Donna Hughes rant is typical of the
不，我想他们确实有。我认为法国也有一些糟糕的时尚。我的意思是，重要的是要记住，在整个这段时期，这些人吃的是70年代的食物。所以想象一下那有多令人沮丧。是的，黑森林蛋糕。好吧，他们吃黑森林蛋糕，但也喝大量的酒，大概是蓝修女葡萄酒。还有黑塔葡萄酒，他们还会喝什么呢？那种装在精致瓶子里、外面有格子装饰的酒？然而，从积极的一面来看，正如你在你精彩的书中提醒我们的那样，孩子们确实有弹跳球。所以情况并非一无是处。他们确实有弹跳球。是的，还有拉力赛直升机自行车。所以我们确实勾选了每一个70年代的选项。总之，多纳休的咆哮是
crisis of confidence at the top. And this is obviously reflecting the state of the economy. So as we've said, inflation's out of control. They're actually giving out all these pay deals that the union leaders themselves think are a little bit bonkers. So it's the union leader's job to defend their members. So they have to keep asking for more. But they are very conscious that this kind of free-for-all is sending the economy towards the abyss. So as we said last time, inflation in Britain at this point is rising five times faster than in any other comparable European country. You know, if you're a shopper, if you're Margaret Thatcher pretending to be an ordinary housewife, the price of sugar has gone up by 200% in 12 months, electricity by 66%, coal by
高层信心危机的典型表现。这显然反映了经济状况。正如我们所说，通货膨胀失控了。他们实际上正在发放所有这些连工会领导人自己都认为有点疯狂的薪酬协议。所以工会领导人的工作是捍卫他们的成员。所以他们必须不断要求更多。但他们非常清楚，这种无序竞争正在将经济推向深渊。所以正如我们上次所说，英国此时的通货膨胀率上升速度是其他任何可比欧洲国家的五倍。你知道，如果你是一个购物者，如果你是假装成普通家庭主妇的玛格丽特·撒切尔，糖价在12个月内上涨了200%，电价上涨了66%，煤炭上涨了
47%, the price of milk has doubled. If you're old, if you're living off your savings or a pension, it's being eaten away every week by inflation. If you're self-employed, if you belong to a much smaller and weaker union or no union at all, you are in real trouble. And even Labour papers by this point are hammering the government on this issue. And what really alarms people is that the government just seemed completely powerless to do anything.
47%，牛奶价格翻了一番。如果你老了，如果你靠积蓄或养老金生活，它每周都会被通货膨胀侵蚀。如果你是自雇人士，如果你属于一个规模更小、更弱的工会，或者根本没有工会，你就真的有麻烦了。甚至连工党报纸此时也在就这个问题抨击政府。真正让人们感到惊恐的是，政府似乎完全无力采取任何行动。
I mean, there is a definite sort of pierced armour feel to all this. The economist says Britain's dream of apocalypse is horribly close to coming true. The Sunday Mirror, a Labour paper, Why are we waiting? Isn't it obvious that the government must act against inflation, that we can't go on like this? So Harold Wilson is obviously the head of the government. He's the prime minister.
我的意思是，这一切确实有一种“盔甲被刺穿”的感觉。《经济学人》说，英国的末日梦离现实可怕地接近。《星期日镜报》，一份工党报纸，写道：“我们还在等什么？政府必须采取行动对抗通货膨胀，我们不能再这样下去了，这难道不明显吗？”所以哈罗德·威尔逊显然是政府首脑。他是首相。
But he's depressed and torpid. Yeah, and he's drinking as brandy and Marcia is giving him a hard time. The person who has primary responsibility for dealing with all this is the Chancellor, Dennis Healy. And we haven't seen much of him since the 1974 series that we did two years ago. And it's important to remind people that he is an absolutely tremendous. man. History's greatest eyebrows. His history's greatest eyebrows, exactly. So he came from West Yorkshire. He went to Balliol College, Oxford, tremendous feat. He fought with great courage in North Africa and in Italy. He was the military landing officer for the Allies at Anzio, so, you know, really put himself
但他很沮丧，反应迟钝。是的，他在喝白兰地，玛莎让他很难受。负责处理这一切的主要责任人是财政大臣丹尼斯·希利。自两年前我们制作1974年系列节目以来，我们就没怎么见过他。提醒人们他是一个非常了不起的人很重要。历史上最伟大的眉毛。他拥有历史上最伟大的眉毛，没错。他来自西约克郡。他去了牛津大学贝利奥尔学院，这是一项了不起的成就。他在北非和意大利英勇作战。他是盟军在安齐奥的军事登陆官，所以，你知道，他真的把自己
in harm's way. Then he became an MP on the right of the Labour Party. And as you say Tom, he is best known for his enormous eyebrows. But he's also very, I mean, he's famously, clever and he loves to advertise his cleverness. He doesn't hide his eyes under a bushel, doesn't he? He doesn't. He's very arrogant. He's exceedingly rude. He's a basive bruiser. He despises a lot of his fellow Labour MPs.
置于危险之中。后来他成为了工党右翼的议员。正如你所说，汤姆，他最出名的是他那巨大的眉毛。但他也非常，我的意思是，他以聪明著称，而且他喜欢炫耀自己的聪明。他不会把自己的才华藏在斗篷下，不是吗？他不会。他非常傲慢。他极其粗鲁。他是一个咄咄逼人的打手。他鄙视许多工党议员同事。
And he much prefers, as he will always tell you, Emily Dickinson, Flobert, Tijanef, all these kind of people. So this is his hinterland. Yeah. Politicians should have a hinterland. You are never allowed to mention Denisili without mentioning the fact. that he had a hinterland. And actually he wrote a book, which I have,
正如他总是会告诉你的那样，他更喜欢艾米莉·狄金森、福楼拜、屠格涅夫，所有这些类型的人。这就是他的背景。是的。政治家应该有背景。你永远不能在不提及这一事实的情况下提到丹尼斯·希利。
all about his hinterland, which is a brilliant thing to do. He basically wrote a book called My Secret Planet, which is basically a book about how clever he was. It was basically a list of his favorite poets, his favorite authors. They're more recondite and obscure, the better. Just so he could show off.
他有一个背景，他实际上写了一本书，我也有，全是关于他的背景的，这是一件很棒的事情。他基本上写了一本名为《我的秘密星球》的书，这基本上是一本关于他有多聪明的书。这基本上是他最喜欢的诗人、最喜欢的作家的名单。它们越深奥、越晦涩越好。只是为了让他炫耀。
And every now and again, there'd be a moment in this book where he'd say, Roy Jenkins, of course, had never read Dusty F's in the original, or whatever it might be. Because also the other thing is, he's incredibly easy to impersonate.
时不时地，这本书里会出现这样一个时刻，他会说，罗伊·詹金斯当然从来没读过原文版的《杜斯蒂·F》，或者诸如此类的话。因为还有一点，他非常容易模仿。
And this is the golden age of beige impersonations as featured by Mike Yarwood, who coined the phrase silly billy that Dennis Healy's always meant to be saying but doesn't. And then Dennis Healy does actually take it up and starts using it. And to his massive credit, Dennis Healy also used to go on the Dame Edna Everidge show a lot.
这是迈克·亚伍德所代表的“米色模仿”的黄金时代，他创造了“傻瓜比利”这个词，丹尼斯·希利本应总是这么说，但他其实并没有。后来丹尼斯·希利真的采纳了这个词，并开始使用它。值得称赞的是，丹尼斯·希利也经常参加戴姆·埃德娜·埃弗里奇的节目。
Did you see this? He went on once with Roger Moore and they both had, Dame Edna made them both wear badges. His said Den. Roger Moore said Roger Moore said and they had to perform
你看到了吗？他有一次和罗杰·摩尔一起参加节目，戴姆·埃德娜让他们俩都戴上徽章。他的徽章上写着“丹”，罗杰·摩尔的徽章上写着“罗杰·摩尔”，他们不得不表演
a song and dance number with Dame Edna. I think Healy had only just stepped down as chancellor or something. It was an extraordinary thing to do. So Healy had been Chancellor since 74 and in 74 he had thrown money around
一段歌舞，和戴姆·埃德娜一起。我想希利当时刚卸任财政大臣不久。这真是一件非同寻常的事情。希利从74年开始担任财政大臣，在74年，为了赢得十月大选，他
with gay abandon in order to win the October election. But then in January 75 his treasury officials came to him and they said enough. Like you've got to stop this. This is mad. You've got to change direction.
挥金如土。但到了75年1月，他的财政部官员找到他，对他说“够了”。就像是“你必须停止这种行为。这太疯狂了。你必须改变方向。”
And because Healy is actually a very clever man and he's intellectually self-confident. He's self-confident enough to listen to them and to say, okay, fair enough, I will change. And it's very rare that a chancellor does that actually. It's one of the signal examples in modern British history of a chancellor starting off as one thing and then turning into something else. So he then reinvents himself as something of a monetarist, as somebody who is basically going to use monetary targets to bring inflation down. and in the first half of 1975 what you have is Healy going to all these meetings
因为希利实际上是一个非常聪明的人，他在智力上很自信。他有足够的自信去听取他们的意见，并说：“好吧，有道理，我会改变的。”实际上，财政大臣能做到这一点非常罕见。这是英国现代史上财政大臣从一种状态转变为另一种状态的典型例子。于是他把自己重塑为某种货币主义者，一个基本上打算利用货币目标来降低通货膨胀的人。在1975年上半年，希利参加了所有这些会议，
with the other Labour ministers and he says to them again and again look this social contract that we've got with the unions is a complete joke it's a complete failure we should stop borrowing so much money inflation is the bill all and end all
和其他工党大臣们在一起，他一次又一次地对他们说，看，我们与工会达成的这份社会契约完全是个笑话，完全是失败的，我们应该停止借这么多钱，通货膨胀才是最重要的问题，
and we absolutely have to get it down and if you're on the Labour left and you're sitting here and Healy in his sort of very rude and arrogant way is telling you this you're very upset and offended by it because you have
我们绝对必须把它降下来。如果你是工党左翼，你坐在这里，而希利以那种非常粗鲁和傲慢的方式告诉你这些，你会感到非常不安和被冒犯，因为你
hate the thought of making any cuts. So Tony Ben, who we talked about last time, Tony Ben's not really that bothered about borrowing money and about inflation. What he wants to see is more spending, loads of new social programmes, more egalitarianism, all of this kind of thing. So by the sort of middle of 75, you have clearly a very big row brewing between the two wings of the Labour Party. And as if that's not bad enough, as the summer goes on, the economic news is getting worse and worse. So two weeks after the referendum, the European referendum on the 20th of June, healy gave the cabinet this kind of
讨厌削减开支的想法。所以托尼·本，我们上次谈到过他，托尼·本并不太在意借钱和通货膨胀。他想看到的是更多的支出、大量的社会项目、更多的平等主义，诸如此类的事情。所以到了75年年中，工党内部两派之间显然正在酝酿一场巨大的争吵。如果这还不够糟糕的话，随着夏天的过去，经济消息变得越来越糟。所以在6月20日欧洲公投两周后，希利向内阁发出了这种
apocalyptic warning, which Barbara Castle, one of his colleagues, recorded in her diary. Inflation, he said was terrifying. Borrowing could stop overnight. Anything could trigger off a disastrous run on the pound and force us into one billion pounds worth of public expenditure cuts this year. There was
末日般的警告，他的同事芭芭拉·卡素尔在日记中记录了下来。他说，通货膨胀令人恐惧。借贷可能一夜之间停止。任何事情都可能引发英镑的灾难性暴跌，并迫使我们今年削减十亿英镑的公共支出。当时
not a minute to waste. But of course they are specialists in waiting minutes because they've got their tiny majority. Wilson is so anxious about provoking the left that he'd rather do nothing. He'd rather carry on sliding than cause a split in his party. Anyway, Healy was quite right. Ten days later, on the 30th of June, the pound started to slide.
一分钟都不能浪费。但当然，他们是“等待时间”的专家，因为他们只有微弱的多数席位。威尔逊非常担心激怒左翼，以至于他宁愿什么都不做。他宁愿继续下滑，也不愿导致党内分裂。总之，希利是对的。十天后，即6月30日，英镑开始下滑。
And it slides and slides. And in four hours, it fell from $2.23 to $2.17. And at that stage, that was the quickest fall in the pound's value in history. But presumably this is seen on the left of the Labour Party. as the names of Zurich kicking in, international finance, doing its worse. Exactly right. So if you're on the left of the Labour Party, if you're Tony Benn, you look at this and you say, well, this is international capitalism conspiring against British socialism. You know, that's, you basically say, why should we listen to what foreign speculators and bankers
它不断下滑。在四个小时内，它从2.23美元跌至2.17美元。在当时，这是英镑历史上最快的跌幅。但据推测，这在工党左翼看来是苏黎世的“名字”在起作用，是国际金融在作恶。完全正确。所以如果你是工党左翼，如果你是托尼·本，你看着这一切，你会说，好吧，这是国际资本主义在密谋反对英国社会主义。你知道，你基本上会说，我们为什么要听外国投机者和银行家
want us to do? We just plow on, you know, and if necessary we'll put up tariff, we'll come onto Tony Ben's programme. We, if necessary, put up huge tariff walls and protection. barriers and stuff when we seal ourselves off. It's the argument that Andy Burner makes about, you know, don't be in hock to the capital markets and Zach Polanski saying it as well. So it's a kind of a perspective that's coming back into fashion now. So I'm going to give a, I'm going to portray my hand here. I think it's a very good argument to make when you're not actually in hock to the capitalist.
想要我们做什么？我们只是继续前进，你知道，如果有必要，我们会设置关税，我们稍后会谈到托尼·本的纲领。我们如果有必要，会设置巨大的关税壁垒和保护屏障，当我们把自己封闭起来时。这就是安迪·伯纳所说的，你知道，不要受制于资本市场，扎克·波兰斯基也这么说。所以这是一种现在又开始流行的观点。所以我要表明我的立场了。我认为当你实际上并没有受制于资本家时，这是一个很好的论点。
You know, to the capital markets, you don't need to borrow any money. I think if you're trying to borrow enormous sums of money, in my experience, you have to listen to the lender. Otherwise, they won't lend you the money. Anyway, there is this huge row inside Downing Street about what to do. And they finally hammer out a sort of deal with the unions, a kind of informal deal. The unions promise that they will cap all wage increases at £6 a week.
你知道，对于资本市场，你不需要借钱。我认为如果你试图借入巨额资金，根据我的经验，你必须听从贷款人的意见。否则，他们就不会借钱给你。总之，唐宁街内部关于该怎么做发生了巨大的争吵。他们最终与工会达成了一种协议，一种非正式的协议。工会承诺将所有工资增长限制在每周6英镑。
And actually, that's quite a big concession from them because it means that even though wages is then still rising at about 14% a year, prices are going up much more than that. So if you're an ordinary working man, you're taking a little bit of a hit in your spending power and living standards. Yeah, it's austerity. I mean, this is what Tony Benn would definitely say. And in the long run, actually, this will catch up with the Labor government right at the end of the decade when union members rebel against it. Anyway, for the time being, it's enough.
实际上，这对他们来说是一个很大的让步，因为这意味着即使工资当时仍以每年约14%的速度增长，物价的上涨幅度却远不止于此。所以如果你是一个普通的工薪阶层，你的消费能力和生活水平会受到一点打击。是的，这就是紧缩政策。我的意思是，这绝对是托尼·本会说的话。从长远来看，这实际上会在十年末追上工党政府，当时工会成员会反抗它。总之，目前来说，这已经足够了。
The pressure on the pound eases a bit. And actually, Britain has been very lucky. You could say Britain was incredibly lucky to have got away with its kind of proflagacy for as long as it did. And one reason is that when the Arab oil nations made their great, you know, when they got their winnings after the oil shock of 1973, a lot of them put their money into sterling. They invested it in sterling. And they didn't do this because they thought that Britain was a great going concern. They actually just almost did it out of sort of sentimental traditionalism. Britain is the banker of the world. Obviously, when you've got loads of money, you put it into the bound. But as one of Dennis Heed's treasury colleagues, I got Edmund Dell, wrote a brilliant book about all this. As Dell said in his book, it was only a matter of time. before the Arabs basically realized this was a terrible place to put their money. And once they took it out, we were going to be in massive trouble. And by the autumn, surprise, surprise, the pressure is going again.
英镑的压力稍微缓解了一些。实际上，英国一直非常幸运。你可以说英国能以这种挥霍无度的状态维持这么久，简直是极其幸运。一个原因是，当阿拉伯产油国在1973年石油危机后获得巨额收益时，他们中的许多人把钱投入了英镑。他们投资了英镑。他们这样做并不是因为他们认为英国是一个伟大的经营实体。他们实际上几乎只是出于一种感性的传统主义。英国是世界银行。显然，当你有很多钱时，你会把它投入英镑。但正如丹尼斯·希利的一位财政部同事——我记得是埃德蒙·戴尔，他写了一本关于这一切的精彩书籍——正如戴尔在书中所说，阿拉伯人意识到这是一个糟糕的投资地只是时间问题。一旦他们把钱撤走，我们就会陷入巨大的麻烦。到了秋天，不出所料，压力又来了。
And the Bank of England, and this will be a theme all this week, the Bank of England was spending hundreds of millions of pounds in its currency reserves to basically buy up sterling and to defend the exchange rate. And is that done for economic reasons or for kind of prestige reasons? I think they're linked. So the prestige reasons, For what some of listeners may think are silly reasons, people like to think that their currency is really valuable and worth something.
而英格兰银行——这将是本周的一个主题——正在花费数亿英镑的外汇储备来购买英镑并捍卫汇率。这是出于经济原因还是出于某种声望原因？我认为它们是相互关联的。所以声望原因，对于一些听众可能认为的愚蠢原因，人们喜欢认为他们的货币非常有价值，值得拥有。
They don't like to see their currency being debauched. And to devalue your currency is seen as a national humiliation. But there's a very good economic reason where you don't want the pound to fall. And that is, the more that the pound falls, the more expensive foreign imports are to buy. As the inflation goes up. Yeah. If you're 70s Britain and you're buying more and more Japanese washing machines and German
他们不喜欢看到自己的货币贬值。货币贬值被视为一种国家耻辱。但有一个非常好的经济理由让你不希望英镑下跌。那就是，英镑跌得越多，购买外国进口商品就越贵。随着通货膨胀上升。是的。如果你是70年代的英国，你购买越来越多的日本洗衣机和德国
cars and so on and so forth, then if the pound falls and you're spending much more on these things, then you've got massive inflation and a hit in the standard of living. And so no government wants to see that. Why aren't the Labour government listening to Dennis Healy? Why isn't the Prime Minister forcing them to do anything about it? Well, this brings us to the main character in the story who is Harold Wilson. So as we saw last time, Wilson is knackered, he's ill, he's increasingly reliance on the brandy bottle. He says to Bernard Donogne here at one point, the trouble with me now is I only have the same old solutions for the same old problems. And then a few weeks after that, so this is in the sort of late summer of 75, he has a
汽车等等，那么如果英镑下跌，而你在这些东西上花费更多，那么你就会面临巨大的通货膨胀和生活水平的下降。所以没有政府愿意看到这一点。为什么工党政府不听丹尼斯·希利的？为什么首相不强迫他们采取任何行动？好吧，这把我们带到了故事的主角，也就是哈罗德·威尔逊。正如我们上次看到的，威尔逊精疲力竭，他病了，越来越依赖白兰地酒瓶。他在某个时候对伯纳德·多诺霍说，我现在的问题是，对于同样的老问题，我只有同样的老办法。在那之后几周，也就是75年夏末，他和
massive argument with his press chief and speechwriter Joe Haynes. Wilson has written himself a draft speech and Haynes says to him, I mean, this is extraordinary the way they used to speak to the Prime Minister. Haynes says to him this is absolutely useless. He says it's full of your old cliches, it's got whole paragraphs repeated from previous speeches. And Wilson snaps at him and says, well, I don't have anything new to say, do I? And Haynes said, well, you might put some of your old ideas in new words. Why don't you try doing that? And this sort of sense that Wilson is, he's definitely on the downward slope. So he's getting, he used to have a brilliant, brilliant memory, but he's getting things wrong in meetings. He's actually skipping meetings.
他的新闻主管兼演讲稿撰写人乔·海恩斯发生了激烈的争吵。威尔逊为自己写了一份演讲草稿，海恩斯对他说——我的意思是，他们过去对首相说话的方式真是非同寻常——海恩斯对他说，这完全没用。他说，这全是你的老生常谈，整段整段地重复以前的演讲。威尔逊对他发火说，好吧，我没什么新鲜话可说，不是吗？海恩斯说，好吧，你可以用新的词汇来表达你的一些旧想法。你为什么不试着这样做呢？这种感觉就是威尔逊，他绝对是在走下坡路。所以他开始，他过去有非常非常好的记忆力，但他现在在会议上弄错了事情。他实际上在逃避会议。
He's making excuses to skip meetings. He says he's got a cold, says he's got stomach upset. He's an increasingly sad figure. And the moment that I think captures this really nicely, it's December 1975, they're having a meeting surprise, surprise about cuts with Dennis Healy. And somebody says, well, we can't really decide, we'll have to have a meeting of the full cabinet tomorrow on Friday to discuss it. And Wilson, the Prime Minister, says, well, I can't make Friday. And Bernard Donahue writes in his diary that in full view of everybody else, Healy turned to him and said, it might be better for all of us if you weren't there.
他找借口逃避会议。他说他感冒了，说他胃不舒服。他是一个越来越悲伤的人物。我认为最能捕捉到这一点的一刻是1975年12月，他们正在开会——不出所料——关于与丹尼斯·希利一起削减开支的问题。有人说，好吧，我们无法真正决定，我们明天周五必须召开全体内阁会议来讨论它。而首相威尔逊说，好吧，我周五没空。伯纳德·多诺霍在日记中写道，在所有人面前，希利转向他说，如果你不在场，对我们所有人来说可能更好。
and Wilson pretended not to hear this and then he went out to the toilet and Bernard Donahue followed him out and found him in the toilet with kind of with his head in his hands absolutely crushed and just said very weakly I'm so exhausted I'm so tired
威尔逊假装没听见，然后他去上厕所了，伯纳德·多诺霍跟着他出去，发现他在厕所里，双手抱头，彻底崩溃了，只是非常虚弱地说：“我太累了，我太累了。”
and he just he basically allowed himself to be insulted in this way by his own chancellor in front of everybody he did nothing at all about it and he is as Donaghy writes a month later privately we know he's blown he's no more interest no more ideas
他基本上允许自己在所有人面前被自己的财政大臣这样侮辱，他对此什么也没做。正如多诺霍一个月后私下写道，我们知道他完了，他没有兴趣，没有想法，
no appetite for power so it is quite a sad story I think yeah very sad because he was he was such a brilliant able go-getting white technology kind of guy wasn't he in the 60s he was and now the sheen has worn off the Gannock's plastic raincoats
没有权力欲望，所以这是一个相当悲伤的故事，我想。是的，非常悲伤，因为他曾经是那么聪明、能干、积极进取、代表“白热化技术”的那种人，不是吗？在60年代他是，而现在，加内特塑料雨衣的光泽已经磨损了。
yeah Gannett there would be turning up again later they will yeah shop soiled is the word that's always used isn't it well I think I use that word a lot with I mean you say always used nobody else writes about Howard Wilson to be honest. So what lies behind this? We talked about all the business of Mars here and all that last time,
是的，加内特，他们稍后还会出现，是的。店里弄脏了，这是总是被用到的词，不是吗？好吧，我想我经常用这个词，我的意思是，你说总是被用到，老实说，没有其他人写哈罗德·威尔逊。那么这背后是什么呢？我们上次谈到了马西亚的所有事情，
but actually Wilson by now has decided to walk away. For years he had been saying to people, if I ever got back into power, I'd probably only do two more years. But people didn't believe him because they thought, oh, he's so ambitious and so wily, he'd never walk away. But in the summer of 1975, he said to Joe Haynes, I want to go sooner rather than later. I'm very tired.
但实际上威尔逊现在已经决定离开了。多年来他一直对人说，如果我能重掌权力，我可能只会再做两年。但人们不相信他，因为他们认为，哦，他太有野心、太狡猾了，他永远不会离开。但在1975年夏天，他对乔·海恩斯说，我想早点走，而不是晚点走。我太累了。
And he also said, I am totally fed up with the Labour Party and I find its behaviour intolerable. And probably that summer, late that summer, he tells the Queen. And the Queen loves him, doesn't she? He's her favourite. It was a proper monarchist. He's a sort of, he's quite, they talk probably about, I bet they talk about Agatha Christie or something. Yeah, and they'd bond over the Tupperware. Yeah, they absolutely would.
他还说，我完全厌倦了工党，我觉得它的行为令人无法容忍。可能在那个夏天，那个夏末，他告诉了女王。女王很喜欢他，不是吗？他是她的最爱。他是一个真正的君主主义者。他是一个，他相当，他们可能谈论，我敢打赌他们谈论阿加莎·克里斯蒂之类的。是的，他们会因为特百惠而建立联系。是的，他们绝对会。
So the way he tells her is so sort of, it's so fitting. They were staying on Balmoral, him and M. Mary and they went to, there was some sort of cottage on the estate in Balmoral and the Queen drove them there in a Land Rover and they went to this cottage and it was almost like Marion Thoinette at Le Petitriano or whatever. The Queen made tea for Harold Wilson and Mary and then started doing the washing up and while she was doing the washing up Wilson came and talked to her at the sink and said, I'm going to resign. So it's a kitchen sink drama. Very good Tom. Now he at first he thought he might go that autumn but basically Marcia
所以他告诉她的方式是如此的，如此贴切。他们当时住在巴尔莫勒尔，他和玛丽，他们去了，庄园里有某种小屋，女王开着路虎带他们去了那里，他们去了那个小屋，这几乎就像玛丽·安托瓦内特在小特里亚农宫一样。女王为哈罗德·威尔逊和玛丽泡了茶，然后开始洗碗，当她在洗碗时，威尔逊走过来在水槽边对她说，我要辞职了。所以这是一出“厨房水槽剧”。很好，汤姆。起初他以为他可能会在那年秋天走，但基本上马西亚
persuades him to stay on. She doesn't want him to go because then she'll lose all her, you know, all her power and stuff. I mean, the new prime minister's not going to take her on,
说服他留下来。她不想让他走，因为那样她就会失去她所有的，你知道，所有的权力和东西。我的意思是，新首相不会接纳她，
is he? No, no, no, no. And Donahue and Haynes knew that he was going to go and he kept telling them, you know, I'll go in Biff at Christmas or something and then he would postpone it.
是吗？不，不，不，不。多诺霍和海恩斯知道他要走，他一直告诉他们，你知道，我会在圣诞节左右走，然后他就会推迟。
And they were very frustrated by this because they thought, you know, he's run out of ideas. He probably should go. And as Donahue said, it's a sign of his weakness. He should take a decision and stick to it.
他们对此感到非常沮丧，因为他们认为，你知道，他已经黔驴技穷了。他可能应该走。正如多诺霍所说，这是他软弱的标志。他应该做出决定并坚持下去。
By the beginning of 76, there are lots of rumours going around Whitehall and Westminster, but most people don't really believe them, because they think of Wilson as so wily and so cunning that this is another of his schemes to hold on to power a bit longer. At last he decides on a departure date, well, on an announcement date, I should say. He will announce his departure on Thursday the 11th of March, 1976, which is his 60th birthday. But then fate takes a turn. Because as we said, confidence in the British economy is at a very, very, very low ebb, and it won't take much to trigger another run on the pound. On the 5th of March, that's a week before Wilson is planning to make his
到76年初，白厅和威斯敏斯特到处流传着各种谣言，但大多数人并不真正相信，因为他们认为威尔逊非常狡猾，这不过是他为了继续掌权而耍的又一个花招。最终，他确定了一个离职日期，或者说，我应该说是宣布离职的日期。他将在1976年3月11日星期四，也就是他60岁生日那天宣布离职。但随后命运发生了转折。正如我们所说，人们对英国经济的信心处于极低谷，只要一点点风吹草动就足以引发又一轮英镑抛售。在3月5日，也就是威尔逊计划宣布离职的前一周，
announcement. The Bank of England decides to cut interest rates to try and give the economy a little bit of a boost. And the markets don't like this at all, and people start rushing to sell sterling. And quite soon, the rush turns into a stampede. So by the evening of the following day, the 6th. The pound has now fallen to $1.98. Remember, it was $2.23 a few minutes ago. It's now $1.98, the lowest level in its history. And the Bank of England panics, and it starts desperately buying up sterling. And in total, in the next two weeks, it spends a billion dollars to buy up pounds, to try and preserve the value of the currency. But it's no good. The pound just keeps sliding. So by the 10th, it's down to $1.92. And of course, as a result of all this,
英格兰银行决定降息，试图给经济打一针强心剂。但市场对此非常不满，人们开始疯狂抛售英镑。很快，这种抢购演变成了踩踏。到了第二天，也就是6号的晚上，英镑已经跌至1.98美元。记住，几分钟前它还是2.23美元。现在跌到了1.98美元，这是历史最低水平。英格兰银行陷入恐慌，开始拼命买入英镑。在接下来的两周里，它总共花费了10亿美元来买入英镑，试图维持货币价值。但无济于事，英镑一直在下跌。到了10号，跌至1.92美元。当然，这一切的结果是，
You know, as the pound falls, the danger is that inflation will start to rise. So that night, so the 10th, the Commons voted on yet more Dennis Healy cuts. And to the government's horror, the Labour left rebel, and the government loses by 28 votes, a massive humiliation. Can I just ask, the Tories aren't voting for these cuts? No, the Tories, we always vote against the government. Okay, but they would presumably be in favour of these cuts. Yeah. They're putting party ahead of country.
你知道，随着英镑下跌，危险在于通货膨胀将开始上升。所以那天晚上，也就是10号，下议院对丹尼斯·希利提出的进一步削减开支进行了投票。令政府震惊的是，工党左翼反叛，政府以28票之差落败，这是一种巨大的羞辱。我可以问一下吗，保守党没有投票支持这些削减措施吗？不，保守党，我们总是投票反对政府。好吧，但他们理应支持这些削减措施。是的。他们把党派利益置于国家利益之上。
Oh, I mean, that's just not how politics works, Tom. You're in the opposition. Your duty is to oppose. I mean, basically, Mrs. Satcher agrees with Dennis Healy's diagnosis, right? She does, but I mean, they would say, I mean, any opposition in this circumstance says this government is, you know, should be turfed out, we should get rid of them and get a new government in, and we vote against them. I mean, it would be unheard of, really, for the opposition to vote with the government
哦，我的意思是，政治运作根本不是那样的，汤姆。你是反对党。你的职责就是反对。我的意思是，基本上，撒切尔夫人同意丹尼斯·希利的诊断，对吧？她是同意，但我的意思是，他们会说，在这种情况下，任何反对党都会说这个政府应该被赶下台，我们应该除掉他们，换一个新政府，所以我们投票反对他们。我的意思是，反对党投票支持政府的经济议程的一部分，这简直是闻所未闻。
on part of the government's own economic agenda. That would be very bizarre. But if the government wins the vote in a kind of Tory, right of the Labour Party alliance, then that's very bad for the government. I'm just playing four-dimensional chess here in a way that clearly Mrs. Satcher wasn't. That is four-dimensional.
那会非常奇怪。但如果政府在某种保守党与工党右翼的联盟中赢得了投票，那对政府来说是非常糟糕的。我在这里玩的是四维象棋，而撒切尔夫人显然没有。那确实是四维的。
I think if you were Howard Wilson and the tourists are always going to vote with you on your economic plans, you'd probably take it because it means you can have a nice lion or something. You don't have to worry about whipping all your elderly MPs into the voting lobby anymore.
我想如果你是哈罗德·威尔逊，而保守党总是投票支持你的经济计划，你可能会接受，因为这意味着你可以睡个懒觉什么的。你再也不用担心要把你那些年迈的议员们赶进投票大厅了。
Yeah, well, I mean, you know, he may have got the top economics degree at Oxford in its history, but he's not as shrewd a political operator as me. No, clearly not. Howard Wilson isn't there for this crucial vote. He's at Marcia's birthday party. So anyway, the next day is the 11th, and it's Howard Wilson's birthday,
是的，好吧，我的意思是，你知道，他可能获得了牛津大学历史上最好的经济学学位，但他不是像我这样精明的政治操盘手。不，显然不是。哈罗德·威尔逊没有参加这次关键的投票。他在玛西娅的生日派对上。所以，第二天是11号，是哈罗德·威尔逊的生日，
and he doesn't make the announcement after all. I mean, to be fair to him, it would be crazy to make the announcement in the middle of this kind of sterling crisis. And instead, a cabinet, when he was going to make the announcement, the cabinet sing happy birthday to him instead, led by Shirley Williams. Do you know what Tony Ben wrote about it in his diary? It was odious. So that evening said Wilson's birthday.
他最终还是没有宣布。说实话，在这种英镑危机中宣布离职简直是疯了。相反，在内阁会议上，当他本该宣布离职时，内阁成员们在雪莉·威廉姆斯的带领下为他唱了生日快乐歌。你知道托尼·本在他的日记里是怎么写的吗？他说这令人作呕。所以那天晚上是威尔逊的生日。
He doesn't have a fun birthday evening because it's a vote of confidence in his government. And it's an incredibly fractious debate. Basically, it's sink or swim for the government. Healy leads for the government, the chancellor, and he spends most of his time actually hammering the left, not the right. So he says, the left are going to betray the whole of our labor movement to its enemies if they don't vote for us.
他没有过一个愉快的生日之夜，因为这是对他政府的一次信任投票。这是一场极其激烈的辩论。基本上，这是政府的生死存亡之战。希利代表政府发言，作为财政大臣，他大部分时间实际上是在抨击左翼，而不是右翼。他说，如果左翼不投票支持我们，他们就会把我们整个工党运动出卖给敌人。
And as they all go to vote, there is a massive row. Now these are in the days before our politics, before Parliament was televised. In fact, before Parliament was even broadcast on the radio. So you could get away with all kinds of behaviour. And Healy actually gets into a brawl. A punch up. A punch up. So he's literally a bruiser.
当他们去投票时，发生了一场巨大的争吵。那是在我们的政治、议会电视转播之前的日子。事实上，甚至在议会通过广播播出之前。所以你可以逃脱各种行为。希利实际上卷入了一场斗殴。一场打斗。一场打斗。所以他确实是个打手。
He's literally a bruiser. And with some of the left-wing MPs, and one of them said to the Times, I think it was the next day, complained. He said, the Chancellor's verbal behaviour was unprinciable and obscene in the extreme. He came across like a drunken oath. What did he say, Dominic? He said, and Callum will have to get his bleeper ready. He said, go and fuck yourselves, you fuck us.
他确实是个打手。他和一些左翼议员发生了冲突，其中一人在第二天向《泰晤士报》投诉。他说，财政大臣的言语行为极其无原则且下流。他表现得像个醉汉。他说了什么，多米尼克？他说，卡勒姆得准备好消音器了。他说，去你们的，你们这些混蛋。
He shouted this at the Labour left, left of his own party. Is it in Hansard? I don't think it is in Hansard. No, it's not in Ansard. Because it says they're going out. Anyway, at one level it works because the rebels fall into line and the government survives. But Dennis Healy, unwittingly, has shot himself in the foot because this is going to be a leadership contest, which there clearly is.
他对着工党左翼，也就是他自己党内的左翼喊道。这在《汉萨德》（议会记录）里吗？我不认为在《汉萨德》里。不，不在《汉萨德》里。因为上面写着他们要出去了。无论如何，在某种程度上它奏效了，因为反叛者归队了，政府幸存了下来。但丹尼斯·希利无意中搬起石头砸了自己的脚，因为这将会有一场领导权之争，显然会有。
He doesn't know it. He will not be well placed, having just shouted this at half of it. of his own party. So Wilson spends the next weekend at Chequers, his country house with his wife Mary. When he comes back to London on the Monday morning the 15th, he listens to the news in his car, and the news says the markets have opened and they're actually pretty calm. And when he gets to number 10, he says to his civil servants, all systems go. Let's do this. So the next day is the Tuesday. It's a regular cabinet meeting. All his ministers come in. And Wilson takes two of them aside beforehand. First of all, he takes Jim Callahan aside, the Foreign Secretary. Callahan
他不知道这一点。他刚刚对党内一半的人喊了这些话，他的处境不会好。所以威尔逊在契克斯（首相乡间别墅）度过了接下来的周末，和他的妻子玛丽在一起。当他在15日星期一早上回到伦敦时，他在车里听新闻，新闻说市场已经开盘，而且实际上相当平静。当他到达唐宁街10号时，他对公务员说，一切准备就绪。我们开始吧。所以第二天是星期二。这是例行的内阁会议。他所有的部长都进来了。威尔逊事先把其中两人拉到一边。首先，他把外交大臣吉姆·卡拉汉拉到一边。卡拉汉
is Wilson's oldest rival and he's been part of his government since 1964. So they've always been sort of slightly wary of each other. Frenomies, do you think? Frenemies, exactly. They're like old prize fighters. And Wilson calls him upstairs and Callahan comes down and he comes down and he's described as looking winded. And when Joe Haynes says, good morning Jim to him. Callahan just says, is it? And then Wilson takes Healy aside. Takes him into the toilet. And Wilson being Wilson, he probably puts on all the taps to make sure they're not being listened to by MI5. We'll come back to this. Healy emerges impassive and he doesn't give anything away. And then they all sit around the cabinet table. Wilson reads this prepared statement. He says, I've been labor leader for 13 years. I've decided to step down, give other people a chance, time for fresh ideas, all of this.
是威尔逊最老的竞争对手，自1964年以来他一直是威尔逊政府的一员。所以他们一直对彼此有点警惕。你觉得是“友敌”吗？正是友敌。他们就像老拳击手。威尔逊把他叫到楼上，卡拉汉下来时，被描述为看起来气喘吁吁。当乔·海恩斯对他说“早上好，吉姆”时，卡拉汉只是说，是吗？然后威尔逊把希利拉到一边。把他带进厕所。威尔逊就是威尔逊，他可能会打开所有的水龙头，以确保他们没有被军情五处窃听。我们稍后再谈这个。希利出来时面无表情，什么也没透露。然后他们都坐在内阁桌旁。威尔逊宣读了这份准备好的声明。他说，我担任工党领袖13年了。我决定辞职，给其他人一个机会，是时候有新的想法了，诸如此类。
some of them started crying Callahan who now has this sort of glint in his eye of somebody who's fancying a shot at the top job he delivers this tribute and he says thank you so much Harold for all you've done for us and all this kind of thing the meeting breaks up they're all in shock Wilson goes off to ring the trade union leaders
有些人开始哭泣。卡拉汉现在眼中闪烁着那种想要争夺最高职位的人的光芒，他发表了悼词，他说，非常感谢哈罗德你为我们所做的一切，诸如此类。会议解散了，他们都处于震惊中。威尔逊去给工会领袖打电话，
that's a sign of where power lies in Britain actually and then he goes up and of course he has to have lunch on his own because of Marcy's prescriptions So the news is travelling fast Just before we get to the break The Times sent a man onto the streets of London To gauge people's reactions that afternoon After the news broke
这实际上是英国权力所在的一个标志，然后他上楼了，当然他必须独自吃午餐，因为玛西娅的处方。所以消息传得很快。在我们休息之前，泰晤士报派了一个人到伦敦街头，去了解人们在那天下午消息传出后的反应。
And most people were absolutely amazed The Wilson was going Kind of unheard of to walk away With no warning in your pomp But there were some very funny responses An old man in a cardigan said You can't control a government With people going against you
大多数人都非常惊讶威尔逊要走。在你的鼎盛时期毫无预兆地离开，这简直是闻所未闻。但也有一些非常有趣的反应。一个穿着开衫的老人说，你不能在人们反对你的情况下控制政府。
I'm a labour man I have to be because I come from Durham I say the trouble with the party Is there's too many of those left wingers in it And then the other man whose contribution I enjoy who was a 78-year-old man in a flat cap who used to work for the local council and he absolutely, he said he hated the left.
我是个工党人，我必须是，因为我来自达勒姆。我说这个党的问题在于里面有太多的左翼分子。然后是另一位我喜欢他的贡献的人，一个戴着平顶帽的78岁老人，他曾经为地方议会工作，他绝对，他说他讨厌左翼。
He said it was the left's fault. They were always having a go at him. There's only so much a man can stand. I hate those left wingers. I despise them. And are these representatives? Or have you just cherry-picked them? No, cherry-picked them, of course.
他说这是左翼的错。他们总是找他麻烦。一个人能忍受的有限。我讨厌那些左翼分子。我鄙视他们。这些是代表吗？还是你只是精挑细选了他们？不，当然是精挑细选的。
Of course they're cherry-picked. Because there must be some people who... Yeah. I mean, particularly they're working for that council from Durham. There must be some people in working in councils in Durham who like The left? I suppose it was fresh in people's minds because Wilson had just had this huge battle with the left.
当然是精挑细选的。因为肯定有一些人……是的。我的意思是，特别是那些在达勒姆为议会工作的人。在达勒姆的议会里肯定有一些人喜欢左翼？我想这在人们的脑海中还很新鲜，因为威尔逊刚刚与左翼进行了这场巨大的战斗。
They've been these stuff business in the House of Commons. Okay, fair enough. So, it's all up for grabs now. Who will the Labour Party pick as the new Prime Minister? Is there perhaps a secret scandal behind Harold Wilson's resignation? And Tom, a scandal involving MI5 bugs in Downing Street, the South African secret police, some lavender note paper, and a blind man on the corner of the Charing Cross Road.
他们在下议院一直有这些争执。好吧，有道理。所以，现在一切都悬而未决了。工党会选谁作为新首相？哈罗德·威尔逊的辞职背后是否隐藏着什么秘密丑闻？汤姆，一个涉及唐宁街军情五处窃听器、南非秘密警察、一些薰衣草色信纸和一个站在查令十字路口盲人的丑闻。
Local news is in decline across Canada, and this is bad news for all of us. With less local news, noise, rumors, and misinformation fill the void, and it gets harder to separate truth from fiction. That's why CBC News is putting more journalists in more places across Canada, reporting on the ground from where you live, telling the stories that matter to all of us, because local news is big news. Choose news, not noise.
加拿大各地的本地新闻正在衰落，这对我们所有人来说都是坏消息。随着本地新闻的减少，噪音、谣言和错误信息填补了空白，区分事实与虚构变得越来越困难。这就是为什么加拿大广播公司新闻部正在加拿大各地部署更多的记者，从你居住的地方进行实地报道，讲述对我们所有人来说都很重要的故事，因为本地新闻就是大新闻。选择新闻，而不是噪音。
CBC News. Hello everyone and welcome back to the rest of history where Harold Wilson has resigned. British politics is in tumult. What happens next, Dominic? Well, there's all kinds of mystery and all kinds of exciting espionage and sexual scandal details come. The general reaction at the time is that there must be some sinister explanation for all this. So most people thought Harold Wilson is so shifty. He would never just walk away.
加拿大广播公司新闻。大家好，欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》，哈罗德·威尔逊已经辞职了。英国政坛一片混乱。接下来会发生什么，多米尼克？嗯，有各种各样的谜团，还有各种令人兴奋的间谍活动和性丑闻细节。当时普遍的反应是，这一切一定有什么阴险的解释。所以大多数人认为哈罗德·威尔逊太狡猾了。他绝不会就这样走掉。
The Sunday Times called it yet another characteristic confidence trick. Wilson's friend Barbara Castle wrote in her diary, she said, I wonder what exactly Harold is up to. More than meets the eye, I have no doubt. It's like, is it Metternick when Talleyron died? And he said, I wonder what he means by that. It's that kind of order, isn't it? Exactly.
《星期日泰晤士报》称这是又一个典型的骗局。威尔逊的朋友芭芭拉·卡斯尔在日记中写道，她说，我想知道哈罗德到底在搞什么鬼。毫无疑问，事情远没有表面看起来那么简单。就像塔列朗去世时梅特涅说的那样，他说，我想知道他这话是什么意思。就是那种感觉，对吧？正是如此。
So the most common rumor at the time, which goes around Westminster, and has never really gone away, to be honest, is that he was being framed by the security services over some hideous financial or sexual scandal. And we will come on to this later on because Wilson himself does a lot to fuel these rumours. Anyway, he has his farewell dinner on the 22nd of March and it's a very, very miserable.
所以当时在威斯敏斯特流传最广的谣言，老实说，从未真正消失过，那就是他因为某种可怕的金融或性丑闻而被安全部门陷害了。我们稍后会谈到这一点，因为威尔逊本人做了很多事情来助长这些谣言。无论如何，他在3月22日举行了告别晚宴，那是一个非常、非常悲惨的场合。
And we mentioned 1970s food. It's a very desultory occasion. The only highlight is when a waiter accidentally poured Hollandey's sauce all over Dennis Healy. Accidentally? Yeah, maybe it's somebody who's got investments and is paying 98% in tax on his investments or something. Tony Ben said in his diary afterwards,
我们提到了70年代的食物。这是一个非常令人沮丧的场合。唯一的亮点是服务员不小心把荷兰酱洒在了丹尼斯·希利身上。不小心？是的，也许是某个有投资的人，他的投资要缴纳98%的税，或者类似的情况。托尼·本后来在日记中说，
The pathetic thing about tonight when Tony Bennett is so harsh about Harold Wilson, the pathetic thing about tonight is that nobody is sad that he was going. He hasn't inspired any affection. He's fudged every issue, dodged every difficulty,
今晚令人悲哀的事情，当托尼·本对哈罗德·威尔逊如此严厉时，今晚令人悲哀的事情是，没有人为他的离开感到难过。他没有激发任何感情。他敷衍了每一个问题，回避了每一个困难，
but kept us in power, kept us together and ground out the administrative decisions. But someone's going to miss him, right? The queen? Well, the queen, actually, so the queen comes the next day for dinner at number 10.
但让我们保持执政，让我们团结在一起，并完成了行政决策。但总有人会想念他，对吧？女王？嗯，女王，实际上，女王第二天来到唐宁街10号共进晚餐。
And this is a signal honor. The queen only did this, think for Churchill when he resigned, so for Winston and for Harold Wilson. So she really, I mean, she thinks of Harold Wilson as a leader on the, on the scale of Churchill. Yeah, the two titans of which is 20th century politics. I'm sure, like international listeners. I mean, people probably study Wilson, don't they? In like schools in Australia and American stuff. It's one of the great men of history. Yeah, I imagine that's why we're not shedding listeners to this episode in any way, in the Sydney and New York. So there's then a hiatus while they wait for the Labour MPs to a
这是一种极高的荣誉。女王只为丘吉尔辞职时这样做过，所以是为温斯顿和哈罗德·威尔逊。所以她真的，我的意思是，她认为哈罗德·威尔逊是一位丘吉尔级别的领导人。是的，20世纪政治的两位巨人。我相信，像国际听众。我的意思是，人们可能研究威尔逊，不是吗？在澳大利亚和美国的学校里。他是历史上伟大的人物之一。是的，我想这就是为什么我们没有在悉尼和纽约流失听众的原因。所以，在他们等待工党议员选举新领袖期间，有一个间歇期。
elect a new leader. And that takes another two weeks. At the end of March, there is a sign of trouble to come. Joe Haynes says to his friend Bernardinehu that he has seen, and I quote, 50 names for peers and knighthoods, all in Marcia's handwriting on a sheet of lavender colored notepaper simply ticked by Harold Wilson. We will come back to this. So remember this lavender notepaper. Wilson finally leaves on the 5th of April when the Labour MPs have finally picked a successor, we'll tell you who the successor is at the end of the episode. There was a last lunch for his wife and all his aides. Surprise, they have to stand around for 45 minutes waiting for Marcia to join them. You know, one last little power play from Marcia. And Donahue says in his
那又花了两个星期。三月底，出现了麻烦的迹象。乔·海恩斯告诉他的朋友伯纳德·多诺霍，他看到了，我引用一下，50个贵族和爵士头衔的名单，全部是用玛西娅的笔迹写在一张薰衣草色的信纸上，由哈罗德·威尔逊简单地打勾。我们稍后会回到这一点。所以记住这张薰衣草色的信纸。威尔逊最终在4月5日离开，当时工党议员终于选出了继任者，我们会在本集结束时告诉你们继任者是谁。他为他的妻子和所有助手举行了最后一次午餐。令人惊讶的是，他们不得不站着等了45分钟，等着玛西娅加入他们。你知道，玛西娅最后一次权力游戏。多诺霍后来在
diary afterwards, he says it was an embarrassing way to go out, but fitting. Harold Wilson went out as he came in, a remarkable man, but too often humiliated and made shabby by this sad association. And the sad association is with Marcia. With Marcia. But this is not quite the end of the story because that lavender-colored list. So this was Wilson's resignation honors list. For our overseas listeners, when you resign as Prime Minister, you have one last kind of little chance to dole out patronage to, you know, your cronies and to people you, you know, who've helped you and all this kind of thing. And this has never before been an issue for an outgoing Prime Minister, but in Wilson's case, it's toxic for his reputation. For weeks, for the last couple of
日记中说，他说这是一种尴尬的离开方式，但很贴切。哈罗德·威尔逊离开时正如他来时一样，一个非凡的人，但太常被这种悲哀的联系所羞辱和变得卑微。而这种悲哀的联系就是玛西娅。与玛西娅。但这并不是故事的终点，因为那张薰衣草色的名单。所以这是威尔逊的辞职荣誉名单。对于我们的海外听众，当你辞职担任首相时，你有最后一次机会向你的亲信和那些帮助过你的人分发恩惠。这对于即将离任的首相来说从来不是问题，但在威尔逊的案例中，这对他的声誉是有毒的。在最后几周，
a couple of weeks inside number 10 they had been gathering rumors this was going to be a massive problem some of wilson's civil servants had complained to him that the list was was bonkers that it was full of people in the media who had promised to pay him money for books or for tv series and things and it's very clear from donahue's diary the person they thought had drawn up the list was marcia williams it's marcia's last chance to influence honours and she is going for the lot and he and Joe Haynes had some massive rows with Wilson in the final days, begging him to change the list. He is not prepared to listen.
在唐宁街10号内部，他们一直在收集谣言，这将会是一个巨大的问题。威尔逊的一些公务员向他抱怨说，这份名单是疯了，里面全是媒体界的人，他们承诺付钱给他买书或拍电视剧之类的。从多诺霍的日记中可以清楚地看出，他们认为起草这份名单的人是玛西娅·威廉姆斯。这是玛西娅最后一次影响荣誉的机会，她要争取全部。他和乔·海恩斯在最后几天与威尔逊发生了激烈的争吵，恳求他修改名单。他根本不准备听。
He is suicidal. He doesn't seem to care about the reaction to this final and scandalous use of patronage. He just wants to be rid of the whole thing and to buy some peace with Marcia. Do you think it's the onset of dementia? I think it's not caring. I think it's, Wilson was always incredibly weak when it came to Marcia. I think, you know, some of the quotes from the first half,
他自暴自弃。他似乎不在乎这种最后且丑陋的恩惠使用方式所带来的反应。他只是想摆脱这一切，并用玛西娅换取一些平静。你认为这是痴呆症的开始吗？我认为是不在乎。我认为，威尔逊在玛西娅面前总是非常软弱。我想，你知道，上半部分的一些引语，
after the episode where Donahue says, you know, he's tired, he's, he's blown, he doesn't care. I think it's that, actually. I think he just basically thought, yeah, why not? You know, who cares? I just wonder whether it's expressive of a kind of mental decline as well. Oh, there's no doubt there's a mental decline. How much that is to do with the dementia that basically is consuming him by the beginning
在多诺霍说他累了、他完了、他不在乎的那一集之后。我认为实际上就是那样。我想他基本上只是想，是的，为什么不呢？你知道，谁在乎呢？我只是想知道这是否也表现出一种精神衰退。哦，毫无疑问有精神衰退。这在多大程度上与到80年代初基本上吞噬他的痴呆症有关？或者这在多大程度上只是精疲力竭、酗酒、压力？很难区分这两件事。
of the 1980s? Or how much this is just exhaustion, drinking, the stress. It's hard to distinguish those two things. things. And I think it's not a well man. But he's not a well man at all. No, exactly. Then there's a long delay.
事情。而且我认为他不是一个健康的人。他根本不是一个健康的人。不，正是如此。然后有很长的延迟。
The list isn't published. And the reason is that the Bank of England, the home office and the inland revenue have complained about some of the names on the list. And Haynes said to Bernard Donahue, there are people on that list that Scotland Yard might in due course wish to interview, which is not a good sign. And then finally, at the end of May, the list is published. And the reaction is a complete meltdown. So there are 42 names on the list And actually most of them are pretty standard They are like the staff at Downing Street
名单没有公布。原因是英格兰银行、内政部和税务局对名单上的一些名字提出了投诉。海恩斯告诉伯纳德·多诺霍，名单上有些人苏格兰场可能在适当的时候希望进行询问，这不是一个好迹象。然后终于在五月底，名单公布了。反应是一场彻底的崩溃。名单上有42个名字，实际上大多数都很标准。他们就像唐宁街的工作人员，
The housekeepers at checkers This kind of thing But some of the names are inflammatory So Wilson's publisher, George Videnfeldt He gets a peerage A property developer called Eric Miller Gets a knighthood Corporate Raiders James Goldsmith
契克斯的管家，诸如此类。但有些名字具有煽动性。所以威尔逊的出版商乔治·维登菲尔德，他获得了一个爵位。一个叫埃里克·米勒的房地产开发商，获得了一个骑士头衔。企业掠夺者詹姆斯·戈德史密斯，
Later of the Was it the referendum party Yeah and Father of Jemima Yes and Zach And Zach and Ben So James Goldsmith, he gets a knighthood. Another corporate raider called James Hansen gets a knighthood. The man who had made Wilson's raincoats,
后来是公投党的，是的，杰迈玛的父亲，还有扎克，还有本。所以詹姆斯·戈德史密斯，他获得了一个骑士头衔。另一个叫詹姆斯·汉森的企业掠夺者获得了一个骑士头衔。那个制造威尔逊雨衣的人，
so the Gannix raincoat tycoon, Joseph, already Sir Joseph Kagan, he gets a peerage. You see, I love a topic on the rest of history where you get to have the phrase, Gannix raincoat tycoon. Yeah. There aren't that many. No, there aren't.
也就是Gannex雨衣大亨，约瑟夫，已经是约瑟夫·卡根爵士了，他获得了一个爵位。你看，我喜欢《历史的其余部分》里的一个话题，你可以用上“Gannex雨衣大亨”这个词。是的。没那么多。不，没有。
I go that with Hannibal. No, you don't at all. even Samuel Johnson didn't have a raincoat tycoon, didn't he? So these are not traditional labour people. In fact, a lot of them don't even vote Labor. They are friends of Marciers. So Eric Miller, the property developed, he'd been very close to her. He'd possibly been her lover.
我和汉尼拔一起去。不，你根本没有。甚至塞缪尔·约翰逊也没有雨衣大亨，不是吗？所以这些不是传统的工党人。事实上，他们中很多人甚至不投工党。他们是玛西娅的朋友。所以埃里克·米勒，那个房地产开发商，他一直和她很亲近。他可能一直是她的情人。
There were claims that he had bought her a muse flat in the West End. James Goldsmith, there were claims that he had promised to make her a director of his firm and that he was paying her son's private school fees. and all the newspapers said this was absolutely appalling. The Times. By his last act of patronage, Harold Wilson has succeeded in reducing himself and not only himself. He has demeaned the office of Prime Minister. And actually, Labour MPs were appalled by this.
有说法称他曾在西区给她买了一套公寓。詹姆斯·戈德史密斯，有说法称他承诺让她担任他公司的董事，并且他在支付她儿子的私立学校学费。所有的报纸都说这绝对是令人震惊的。《泰晤士报》说，通过他最后一次恩惠行为，哈罗德·威尔逊成功地贬低了自己，不仅是他自己。他贬低了首相的职位。实际上，工党议员对此感到震惊。
So what about Tony Ben? Tony Ben, well, I mean, he said it was odious when they sang happy birthday to Wilson, so he's not going to be best pleased by this. That he should pick inadequate buccaneering, sharp sheisters for his honours was disgust. It was unsavory, disreputable, and it just told the whole Wilson's story in a single episode. And Haynes and Donahue go around everywhere, and they say to everybody, this is Marcia's list. She wrote it on a lavender note paper. Wilson is an absolute weakling of a man, and he just handed it in.
那么托尼·本呢？托尼·本，嗯，我的意思是，当他们为威尔逊唱生日快乐歌时，他说这令人作呕，所以他不会对此感到高兴。他竟然挑选了不称职的、掠夺性的、尖刻的骗子来获得他的荣誉，这令人厌恶。这令人不快、名声扫地，而且在一个单一的事件中讲述了整个威尔逊的故事。海恩斯和多诺霍到处走，他们对每个人说，这是玛西娅的名单。她把它写在薰衣草色的信纸上。威尔逊是一个绝对软弱的人，他只是把它交了上去。
Now, Marcia and Wilson denied this. Wilson said this is sexism, and Marcia said this is snobbery because you don't like the people on the list. And actually, the row that followed lasted for another. I'm just doing the maths, more than 35 years, because Marcy was so angry about this that she was still suing people well into the 21st century. To what effect? She would win.
现在，玛西娅和威尔逊否认了这一点。威尔逊说这是性别歧视，玛西娅说这是势利，因为你不喜欢名单上的人。实际上，随后的争吵持续了另一个。我正在计算，超过35年，因为玛西娅对此非常生气，以至于她在21世纪还在起诉别人。有什么效果？她会赢。
You couldn't prove that she had done it, and she would say, she generally, I think, won the case. And so, what's the consensus now? She definitely did it. Oh, right, okay. The BBC did a drama in the late 2000s, called, I think, the lavender list, and she basically forced them to apologize and to withdraw it.
你无法证明是她做的，她会说，我认为她通常赢了官司。那么，现在的共识是什么？她确实做了。哦，好吧，明白了。英国广播公司在2000年代末制作了一部名为《薰衣草名单》的剧，她基本上强迫他们道歉并撤回了它。
She said, you know, there's no evidence, this is a lie, this is, you know, all of this kind of thing. Emily, who is our head of written content, says there are extraordinary carry BJ parallels. So listeners can read into that what they will. But she's not wrong, right? I mean, the idea that there's a sort of a prime minister who's handing out, a departing prime minister handing out sort of bounty to his cronies, And actually, there's some sinister female in the background who is pulling the strings. I mean, that's the sort of Lady Macbeth figure.
她说，你知道，没有证据，这是谎言，这是，你知道，所有这些事情。艾米丽，我们的书面内容主管，说有非凡的鲍里斯·约翰逊式的相似之处。所以听众可以随心所欲地解读。但她没说错，对吧？我的意思是，一个即将离任的首相向他的亲信分发赏金，而且实际上，背景中有一个阴险的女性在幕后操纵。我的意思是，那是麦克白夫人式的人物。
I mean, you could argue, I suppose, that this is sexism. But in this case, I'm not sure that it is. And what's disastrous for Wilson is the two of the people on the list, Scotland Yard does wish to interview them. So Eric Miller, who was the guy who had supposedly bought Marcia a flat, a year later, he was charged with fraud, theft and forgery, and he shot himself. Oh, no. So that looked very bad for Wilson.
我的意思是，你可以争辩说，这可能是性别歧视。但在这种情况下，我不确定是这样。对威尔逊来说灾难性的是，名单上的两个人，苏格兰场确实希望询问他们。所以埃里克·米勒，那个据称给玛西娅买公寓的人，一年后，他被指控欺诈、盗窃和伪造，然后他自杀了。哦，不。所以这对威尔逊来说看起来非常糟糕。
And what about the Ganex raincoat tycoon? How does he bear up? Oh, no, this is a terrible story. The Gannix raincoat tycoon, Joseph Kagan. I mean, he's the sort of poster boy for Harold Wilson's resignation on his list. He was charged with tax evasion in 1978. He was charged bizarrely with stealing barrels of dye from his own raincoat company. Wow.
那么那个Gannex雨衣大亨呢？他怎么样？哦，不，这是一个可怕的故事。Gannex雨衣大亨，约瑟夫·卡根。我的意思是，他是哈罗德·威尔逊辞职荣誉名单的典型代表。他在1978年被指控逃税。他被奇怪地指控从他自己的雨衣公司偷窃染料桶。哇。
What was he doing with it? I don't know. Maybe secretly dying, making rival raincoats, making his own raincoats, who knows? Dying them lavender. Yeah, exactly. He ended up in prison where he literally sewed mailbags and he lost his knighthood but not his peerage and he returned to the House of Lords and became a campaigner for penal reform. But this is not the only blow to Harold Wilson's reputation. We are moving fast towards that blind man on the Charing Cross Road. So in the 1974 series, we described how Wilson had been increasingly paranoid that he was being spied on by the security services. He thought MI5 was stealing his tax documents. He told his ministers that there was a bug in the cabinet room ceiling. And he was also convinced that there was some sort of listing device hidden inside a portrait of Gladstone.
他在用它做什么？我不知道。也许在秘密染色，制作竞争对手的雨衣，制作他自己的雨衣，谁知道呢？把它们染成薰衣草色。是的，正是如此。他最终进了监狱，在那里他真的缝制邮袋，他失去了骑士头衔，但没有失去爵位，他回到了上议院，成为了一名刑罚改革的倡导者。但这并不是对哈罗德·威尔逊声誉的唯一打击。我们正在迅速走向查令十字路口的那个盲人。所以在1974年的系列中，我们描述了威尔逊是如何越来越偏执地认为自己被安全部门监视的。他认为军情五处在窃取他的税务文件。他告诉他的部长们内阁会议室的天花板里有一个窃听器。他还确信在格莱斯顿的肖像画里隐藏着某种监听装置。
Now, there is actually a degree of truth in this as we talked about in 2024. In the 1940s, Wilson as a trade minister had visited Moscow. And ever since then, MI5 had kept a file on him under the name Norman John Worthington. and some of the, at least one of the people on that list had links to the KGB. Joseph Kagan, the Gannex raincoat tycoon, used to go and I think play chess with a KGB man from the Soviet embassy.
现在，正如我们在2024年谈到的那样，这实际上有一定程度的真实性。在1940年代，威尔逊作为贸易部长曾访问过莫斯科。从那时起，军情五处就以“诺曼·约翰·沃辛顿”的名字为他保留了一份档案。而且名单上至少有一个人与克格勃有联系。Gannex雨衣大亨约瑟夫·卡根，过去常去和苏联大使馆的一个克格勃人员下棋。
And the claim is that maybe this was because he had family back in Lithuania, but also it could be more dodgy. Also, there were bugs in number 10. They had been installed under Harold McMillan in the 50s. The official history of MI5 by Christopher Andrews says they were defunct and no longer maintained. And to be honest, most of Wilson's own aides and ministers thought he was bonkers about all this. They thought he was paranoid.
声称这可能是因为他在立陶宛有家人，但也可能更可疑。此外，唐宁街10号里确实有窃听器。它们是在50年代哈罗德·麦克米伦执政期间安装的。克里斯托弗·安德鲁斯撰写的军情五处官方历史称它们已经失效，不再维护。老实说，威尔逊的大多数助手和部长都认为他在这方面疯了。他们认为他偏执。
So when Tony Ben brought all this up with James Callahan, Wilson's successor, Callahan told him the story about the Gladstone portrait, but Callahan didn't tell it as in, gosh, maybe there is a bug in the portrait. Callahan told it as a joke against Wilson, to say Wilson's, you know, lost the plot. But Wilson believes all this, and it's compounded by 1976 by a scandal that we talked about in the early days of the rest is history, it's great to welcome back to the show, fan favorite Jeremy Thorpe,
所以当托尼·本向威尔逊的继任者詹姆斯·卡拉汉提起这一切时，卡拉汉告诉了他关于格莱斯顿肖像的故事，但卡拉汉并不是以“天哪，肖像里可能有个窃听器”的方式讲述的。卡拉汉把它当作一个针对威尔逊的笑话，说威尔逊“失去了理智”。但威尔逊相信这一切，并且在1976年被一个丑闻所加剧，我们在《历史的其余部分》早期谈到过，很高兴欢迎回到节目，粉丝最爱杰里米·索普，
the leader of the tiny Liberal Party. So the Liberals, for context, have only 13 MPs. Now, just a month after Wilson left office, Thorpe resigned as leader of the Liberals. And the reason, we did an episode on this in the early days of the show,
微小的自由党领袖。所以自由党，为了背景，只有13名议员。现在，在威尔逊离职仅一个月后，索普辞去了自由党领袖的职务。原因，我们在节目早期做过一集关于这个的，
it turned out that Thorpe had once had an affair with a former stable groom called Norman Scott. Scott held a grudge against him because he believed that Thorpe had stolen his national insurance card. They could never forgive this. Anyway, Scott eventually comes out and he says, Jeremy Thorpe had this affair with me, he stole my national insurance card,
事实证明，索普曾经与一个叫诺曼·斯科特的前马厩马夫有过一段恋情。斯科特对他怀恨在心，因为他认为索普偷了他的国民保险卡。他们永远无法原谅这一点。无论如何，斯科特最终站出来说，杰里米·索普和我有了这段恋情，他偷了我的国民保险卡，
and what is worse, he plotted to have me murdered by an airline pilot on a moor. And I wasn't murdered, but my dog, Rinker, was murdered, and that's terrible. Thorpe, first of all, said this was a lie. He said, I'm being framed by the South African Security Service, boss. They're not called boss. They're called boss. That was what they're called B-O-S. That's so 70s. I'm being framed by boss because I'm anti-apartheid.
更糟糕的是，他密谋让一个航空公司飞行员在荒野上谋杀我。我没有被谋杀，但我的狗，林克，被谋杀了，那太可怕了。索普首先说这是谎言。他说，我被南非安全局陷害了，老板。他们不叫老板。他们叫BOSS。那就是他们被叫的名字，B-O-S。那太70年代了。我被BOSS陷害了，因为我反对种族隔离。
And Wilson believed him. He completely believed him. In February 1976, Wilson made Donahue stay behind after work for three hours to discuss it. And I quote, he is absolutely convinced that the South Africans are behind it. The PM is loving it all, since it appeals to all his obsessions with plots, spies, leaks, conspiracies, etc. Wilson's confidence, by and large, said to him, him, please don't pursue this. This is mad from you.
威尔逊相信了他。他完全相信了他。1976年2月，威尔逊让多诺霍下班后留下来三个小时讨论这件事。我引用一下，他绝对确信南非人在背后操纵。首相很喜欢这一切，因为它迎合了他对阴谋、间谍、泄密、勾结等的所有痴迷。威尔逊的亲信，大体上，对他说，请不要追求这个。这太疯狂了。
So in March, Barbara Castle, one of his ministers had lunch with him, and he said to her, I and Marcia, or as he called her, Detective Inspector Falkander, because she's now Lady Falkander, we have looked into this, and we have conclusive proof that it is a South African plot.
所以三月份，他的部长之一芭芭拉·卡斯尔和他共进午餐，他对她说，我和玛西娅，或者正如他称呼她的那样，法尔坎德侦探督察，因为她现在是法尔坎德夫人，我们已经调查过了，我们有确凿的证据证明这是一个南非阴谋。
Castle said to him, please don't pursue this. This is insane. Why would boss the South African security service? Why would they pick on the Liberal Party, which has only 13 MPs. Why would they go to all this effort to bring down a man that basically nobody outside Britain has ever heard of? I mean, I suppose the South African government hates liberals. It does hate liberals. It hates anti-apartheid campaigns, which thought was. But really, you're going to,
卡斯尔对他说，请不要追求这个。这太疯狂了。为什么BOSS，南非安全局？他们为什么要针对自由党，它只有13名议员。他们为什么要费这么大劲去打倒一个基本上英国以外没人听说过的人？我的意思是，我想南非政府讨厌自由派。它确实讨厌自由派。它讨厌反种族隔离运动，索普就是其中之一。但真的，你要，
well, the problem it is, Castle also says, also Jeremy thought was having an affair with this bloke? How does she know that? Do you know the person who's looked into it for her? Who? Jack Straw, the future Blair Wright Home Secretary, who worked for her, looked into it, did some digging and found out basically, I don't know how they found it out, but it basically was common knowledge by this point. Wilson just wouldn't listen. He was deaf to reason. That same day that he had the lunch for Barbara Castle, he went to the Commons. He said to the Commons, Thorpe is being targeted by South African intelligence. They are using massive reserves of business, money and private agents of various kinds. He said it publicly. Anyway, we've now moved on to May
嗯，问题是，卡斯尔也说，还有杰里米·索普和这个家伙有染？她怎么知道的？你知道为她调查的人是谁吗？谁？杰克·斯特劳，未来的布莱尔派内政大臣，他为她工作，调查了一下，基本上发现了，我不知道他们是怎么发现的，但到这个时候这基本上是常识了。威尔逊就是不听。他听不进道理。就在他和芭芭拉·卡斯尔共进午餐的那天，他去了下议院。他对下议院说，索普正成为南非情报部门的目标。他们正在使用大量的商业资金和各种私人代理人。他公开说了。无论如何，我们现在已经到了五月，
after Wilson's resignation. On the 9th of May, the Sunday Times published letters that showed that Thorpe had been having an affair with this bloke. It's that the letters, Tom, if you may recall, that have the telltale and damning phrase, bunnies can and will go to France. Spoken, very entertaining by Hugh Grant in the dramatisation of this story.
威尔逊辞职后。5月9日，《星期日泰晤士报》发表了信件，显示索普曾与这个家伙有染。就是那些信件，汤姆，如果你还记得的话，里面有那个泄露且致命的短语，“兔子可以而且将会去法国”。在对此故事的戏剧化改编中，由休·格兰特非常有趣地说了出来。
Exactly. You have to imagine that being said with enormous amount of suggestiveness. The next day, Thorpe resigned as leader of the Liberal Party. But Wilson just will not give this up. He is still convinced that Thorpe is being framed. And so two days later, Wilson rang a BBC journalist, a young journalist called Barry Penrose. He basically picked him out of a telephone book or something and said,
正是如此。你必须想象那是带着巨大的暗示意味说出来的。第二天，索普辞去了自由党领袖的职务。但威尔逊就是不放弃。他仍然确信索普是被陷害的。所以两天后，威尔逊给一位英国广播公司的记者打了电话，一个叫巴里·彭罗斯的年轻记者。他基本上是从电话簿里挑出了他，或者类似的东西，然后说，
Come to my flat in Westminster. I've got a story for you. So Penrose roped in this mate of his called Roger Corteur, who was a researcher at the BBC. And they both go along to Wilson's flat in Lord North Street. When they get there, they find Wilson there is puffing on a cigar. Wilson says to them, I think democracy as we know it is in grave danger. He says, the British security services were out to get me for years. They spread rumours that I was running a communist cell in Downing Street.
来我在威斯敏斯特的公寓。我有一个故事要告诉你。所以彭罗斯拉上了他的一个叫罗杰·科特尔的伙伴，他是英国广播公司的一名研究员。他们俩都去了威尔逊在北街勋爵的公寓。当他们到达那里时，他们发现威尔逊在那里抽着雪茄。威尔逊对他们说，我认为我们所知的民主正处于严重危险之中。他说，英国安全部门多年来一直想除掉我。他们散布谣言说我在唐宁街经营一个共产主义小组。
And these BBC blokes can't believe this. I mean, this guy was prime minister just a few weeks ago. And then he's very calm, he's still puffing on his cigar. He says, they were saying that I was tied up with the communists. The link was Marcia. She was supposed to be a dedicated communist. And he goes on to say, he says, Norman Scott, this stable bloke,
这些英国广播公司的家伙简直不敢相信。我的意思是，这家伙几周前还是首相。然后他非常冷静，还在抽着他的雪茄。他说，他们说我和共产党有联系。联系人是玛西娅。她被认为是坚定的共产主义者。他继续说，他说，诺曼·斯科特，这个马厩里的家伙，
is a South African agent, and he's part of a wider conspiracy with MI5. He says, I want you two to crack the case. If you can crack the case, you'll be the wood, wooden Bernstein of British journalism. This is the British Watergate. And then he reaches this mad peroration. He sort of looks them in the eye,
是一个南非特工，他是与军情五处更广泛阴谋的一部分。他说，我希望你们两个破案。如果你们能破案，你们就是英国新闻界的伍德沃德和伯恩斯坦。这就是英国的水门事件。然后他达到了这个疯狂的结尾。他看着他们的眼睛，
puffs on his cigar, and he says, I see myself as the big fat spider in the corner. of the room. Sometimes I speak when I'm asleep. You should both listen. Occasionally, when we meet, I might tell you to go to the Charing Cross Road and kick a blind man standing on the corner. That blind man might tell you something, might lead you somewhere. And they leave. And I mean, obviously, they're like, you know, they're in the 20s or early 30s or something. They cannot believe that the Prime Minister of Great Britain from just a few weeks earlier is telling them this stuff about being a spider and the Charing Cross Road.
抽着他的雪茄，他说，我把自己看作房间角落里那只又大又胖的蜘蛛。有时我在睡着时说话。你们两个都应该听。偶尔，当我们见面时，我可能会告诉你们去查令十字路口踢一个站在角落里的盲人。那个盲人可能会告诉你们一些事情，可能会引导你们去某个地方。然后他们离开了。我的意思是，显然，他们大概20多岁或30出头，他们简直不敢相信几周前还是英国首相的人在告诉他们这些关于蜘蛛和查令十字路口的事情。
And they believe it. And they spend months following his leads. And the irony is they follow this mad cul-de-sac about South Africa and they completely missed the truth that Jeremy thought was not a terribly good person and was trying to kill Norman Scott, which is a madder story, really, than the one they investigate. Eventually the BBC lost patience and said to these guys Penrose and Courtea. Enough did this now.
他们相信了。他们花了几个月时间追踪他的线索。讽刺的是，他们追踪了关于南非的这个疯狂的死胡同，却完全错过了真相，即杰里米·索普并不是一个非常好的人，并且试图杀死诺曼·斯科特，这实际上比他们调查的故事更疯狂。最终英国广播公司失去了耐心，对彭罗斯和科特尔说。够了。
They shut the investigation down. They then sold the story to the newspapers and the Daily Mirror splashed it under the excellent headline, Wilson feared Marcia was being lured into a sex orgy. This is an absolute disaster for Wilson's
他们关闭了调查。他们随后把故事卖给了报纸，《每日镜报》以出色的标题报道了它：“威尔逊担心玛西娅被引诱参加性狂欢”。这对威尔逊的声誉来说是一个绝对的灾难。
reputation. He and Marcia immediately published statements and they said, oh he was just joking about being a spider. He was just joking about the blind man on the Taring Cross Road. But obviously, everybody who knew him in Westminster said, this does sound like the kind of thing Harold would say. He's been saying mad stuff like this for the last few years.
他和玛西娅立即发表了声明，他们说，哦，他只是在开玩笑说自己是蜘蛛。他只是在开玩笑说查令十字路口的盲人。但显然，威斯敏斯特所有认识他的人都说，这听起来确实像哈罗德会说的那种话。过去几年他一直在说这种疯狂的话。
And Marcy has been going around telling everybody that boss are out to get her and Jeremy thought with whom she was quite friendly. Most people at this point just conclude that he's a fantasist. So when Tony Benn again asked James Callahan about it, Callahan said, oh, Harold is just a Walter Mitty, i.e. somebody who's just making up mad stuff in his head. And actually that sets the tone for Wilson after he's. left office because the next few years bring a very sad decline. He'd never had many close friends
玛西到处跟人说老板要找她麻烦，而杰里米（他与玛西关系相当不错）也信以为真。大多数人此时都断定他是个幻想家。所以当托尼·本再次问起詹姆斯·卡拉汉时，卡拉汉说，哦，哈罗德简直就是个“沃尔特·米蒂”，也就是说，他脑子里净想些疯狂的事情。事实上，这为威尔逊卸任后的基调定下了基调，因为接下来的几年里，他经历了一段非常悲惨的衰落。他从未有过多少亲密朋友
in politics and he seems to vanish really after 1976. So within a year or so, there are clear signs, I think, that the Alzheimer's is beginning to claim him. In December 1978, Donahue had a drink with Wilson's former driver. And the driver who's called Bill Howesden said, nobody visits him. He has no friends. It's very sad. He still drinks much too much and his memory is completely going. He can't remember where he's going in the evening. And he had one last turn in the limelight, which people can see bits of on YouTube. It is excruciating. He was invited to be the guest presenter on a BBC chat show called Friday night, Sunday morning. It's in October 1979. It's like a sort of nightmare that you have that you're playing Hamlet and you haven't
在政界，1976年之后他似乎真的消失了。所以我想，大约一年之内，就有明显的迹象表明阿尔茨海默病开始折磨他了。1978年12月，多纳休和威尔逊的前司机喝了一杯。那位名叫比尔·豪斯登的司机说，没人去看他。他没有朋友。这太可悲了。他还是喝得太多，记忆力完全丧失了。他记不起晚上要去哪里。他最后一次出现在聚光灯下，人们可以在YouTube上看到片段。那真是令人痛苦。他受邀担任BBC脱口秀节目《周五晚上，周日早晨》的嘉宾主持人。那是1979年10月。就像你做的一场噩梦，梦见自己在演《哈姆雷特》，却
done, you know, you haven't learned the lines. Because he's sitting there and he's interviewing Pat Phoenix, the actress from, I think, Coronation Street. And he interviews Harry Seekam. And he runs out of questions. There are long pauses. It's really awkward. He stumbles over his words. He can't read the auto queue.
没有，你知道，你还没背下台词。因为他坐在那里采访帕特·菲尼克斯，就是我想是《加冕街》里的那位女演员。他还采访了哈里·西科姆。他没问题可问了。出现了长时间的停顿。真的很尴尬。他说话结结巴巴。他读不出提词器上的字。
Even the short clips on YouTube are actually quite a painful watch. And after that, he pretty much vanished. And the mad thing is, really, he had been the defining politician of the 60s and 70s in Britain. So when he resigned in 1976, all the obituaries, sort of political obituaries said, this will be remembered as the Wilson era. But actually nobody ever uses that phrase. Nobody talks about Wilsonism. And as early as 1979, when Margaret Thatcher became prime minister,
即使是YouTube上的短片看起来也相当痛苦。在那之后，他几乎就消失了。真正疯狂的是，他曾是英国六七十年代最具代表性的政治家。所以当他在1976年辞职时，所有的讣告，某种政治讣告都说，这将被称为威尔逊时代。但实际上没人用过这个词。没人谈论“威尔逊主义”。早在1979年，当玛格丽特·撒切尔成为首相时，
it was as though he'd never existed. He just was completely absent from the political conversation. Some historians, since them, I mean, not that many people write about the Wilson government, to be honest. Some historians, because historians probably tend, academics tend to be slightly more left-leaning. They're keener to rehabilitate him. They say, well, there were the liberal reforms. the 60s. He kept Britain out of the Vietnam War, didn't he? Yeah, I mean, that's the thing he's
就好像他从未存在过一样。他完全从政治对话中消失了。老实说，从那以后，一些历史学家——我是说，没多少人写关于威尔逊政府的事。一些历史学家，因为历史学家可能倾向于，学者往往稍微偏左一点。他们更热衷于为他平反。他们说，嗯，有自由派的改革。60年代。他让英国远离了越南战争，不是吗？是的，我是说，这是他最受
praised for most. I think it's a reasonable thing to praise him for. He refused to get involved with the Vietnam War, but it's a negative achievement rather than a positive one. And I think when he came in in 1964, he would have dreamed of being remembered for much more sort of substantive things. I mean, you said he was brilliantly clever, but I guess it just shows that being clever isn't everything. It's not everything. Yeah, I mean, I think my verdict on him in my book Seasons and the Sun was he was one of the cleverest and kindest men ever to inhabit number 10 but sadly he was also one of the weakest. He used the weakness almost as an asset because it meant that he never upset his party. He was brilliant at keeping his party together. But he also
称赞的地方。我认为称赞他是合理的。他拒绝卷入越南战争，但这是一种消极的成就，而不是积极的成就。我想当他在1964年上台时，他一定梦想过因为更实质性的事情而被人们记住。我是说，你说他非常聪明，但我猜这只是说明聪明并不是一切。并不是一切。是的，我是说，我在我的书《太阳下的季节》中对他的评价是，他是唐宁街10号有史以来最聪明、最善良的人之一，但遗憾的是，他也是最软弱的人之一。他几乎把软弱当作一种资产，因为这意味着他从不让他的党派感到不安。他非常擅长保持党派团结。但他同时也
he did that by deferring decisions and sort of not doing anything. So in Bernard Donahue's memoirs, Donahue who worked for him as his policy advisor like his senior advisor said of him, you know, we wasted our time in Downing Street, completely failed to take to tackle Britain's economic and industrial weakness, and basically all of this left an open goal for Margaret Thatcher in the 80s. And Dennis Healy, who obviously was his chancellor, gave an interview in the 2000s. Someone said, what do you think of Harold Wilson? Dennis Healy said he was a terrible prime minister, which is kind of harsh when you've been his chancellor.
他通过推迟决策和什么都不做来做到这一点。所以在伯纳德·多纳休的回忆录中，曾担任他政策顾问（就像他的高级顾问）的多纳休谈到他时说，你知道，我们在唐宁街浪费了时间，完全没能解决英国的经济和工业疲软问题，基本上所有这些都为80年代的玛格丽特·撒切尔留下了一个空门。而显然曾担任他财政大臣的丹尼斯·希利在2000年代接受采访时，有人问，你觉得哈罗德·威尔逊怎么样？丹尼斯·希利说他是个糟糕的首相，当你曾是他的财政大臣时，这听起来有点刺耳。
Anyway, he's gone now. So someone's got to replace him. Now, in the 70s was a sainer time than today because they didn't allow activists any role in picking the leader. It was just the MPs. Anyway, this contest to succeed Wilson in some ways has been going on for more than a decade. So, starting really when the first Wilson government ran out of trouble in 1966, people had speculated about who would succeed him.
总之，他现在走了。所以必须有人接替他。现在，70年代比今天更理智，因为他们不允许活动人士在挑选领导人方面发挥任何作用。只有国会议员参与。总之，这场接替威尔逊的竞争在某种程度上已经持续了十多年。所以，实际上从1966年第一届威尔逊政府陷入困境开始，人们就一直在猜测谁会接替他。
And for a lot of that period, that intervening period, the favourite, had been a man called Roy Jenkins, who was the Home Secretary and Chancellor in the 60s and is now Home Secretary again. And Roy Jenkins was the son of a minor. He went to Baylor College, Oxford. He has this smooth, urbane, very whiggish style. He can't pronounce his ars properly. He is the darling of the sort of society hostesses of the high-minded.
在那段期间，在那段中间时期，热门人选一直是一个叫罗伊·詹金斯的人，他是60年代的内政大臣和财政大臣，现在又是内政大臣。罗伊·詹金斯是一位矿工的儿子。他去了牛津大学贝利奥尔学院。他有一种圆滑、文雅、非常辉格党的风格。他发不好“r”的音。他是那些高尚的社会女主人眼中的宠儿。
He's a rest his politics man, isn't he? He's so rest his politics. He completely is. He loves Europe. He loves sensible people, moderation, claret, all of this kind of stuff. all of this actually means that he has now fallen out of favour with the Labour Party which has moved to the left because it's all horny-handed sons of toil
他是个“其余政治”的人，不是吗？他太“其余政治”了。他完全是。他热爱欧洲。他热爱理智的人、温和派、红葡萄酒，所有这些东西。所有这些实际上意味着他现在已经失去了工党的青睐，因为工党已经向左转了，因为那全是长满老茧的劳动者之子
Yes, there's a good story told by Neil Kinnock The one of Jenkins's acolytes went canvassing in the House of Commons tea room and he came up to the table that Kinnock was out with another Labour MPs and he said, will you be voting for Roy Jenkins and a Yorkshire MP said no lad, we're all Labour here
是的，尼尔·基诺克讲过一个好故事。詹金斯的追随者之一在下议院茶室拉票，他走到基诺克和其他工党议员坐的桌子旁，他说，你们会投票给罗伊·詹金斯吗？一位约克郡议员说，不，小伙子，我们这里全是工党。
Very good Very good, great repartee So there's Roy Jenkins Another candidate is Jenkins's former best friend and possibly former lover, Anthony Crosland, who he'd been mates with at Oxford. So they'd been very, very close. Crosland had sort of matinee idle good looks
非常好，非常好，精彩的机智问答。所以有罗伊·詹金斯。另一位候选人是詹金斯以前最好的朋友，也可能是以前的情人，安东尼·克罗斯兰，他们在牛津时就是好朋友。所以他们曾经非常、非常亲密。克罗斯兰有一种电影明星般的英俊外表
that has now turned into a lounge lizard, I think when you Google him. He's the Environment Secretary. He had been the party's great intellectual in the 50s. He was a big football fan. He took Henry Kissinger to watch Grimsby Town play Gillingham. Did Kissinger enjoy it? Yeah.
现在已经变成了“休息室里的蜥蜴”，我想当你谷歌他的时候。他是环境大臣。他曾是50年代该党伟大的知识分子。他是个大足球迷。他带亨利·基辛格去看格里姆斯比镇队对阵吉林汉姆队的比赛。基辛格喜欢吗？喜欢。
And after Chisinger left office, after the Gerald Ford fell from power Crossland took Hissinger to watch Chelsea versus Wolverhampton Wanderers And did wolves win? I don't actually know I should that are the stupid of me not to look that up
基辛格卸任后，在杰拉尔德·福特下台后，克罗斯兰带基辛格去看切尔西对阵伍尔弗汉普顿流浪者队的比赛。狼队赢了吗？我其实不知道，我没查过，这太蠢了
but well listeners It's good to let the listeners do a little bit of work I think So there's Jenkins and this is ex-pal Crossland who's a very long shot There's one other candidate on the right really and that is Dennis Healy Yeah Dennis Healy
但是，好吧，听众们，我认为让听众做点功课是件好事。所以有詹金斯，还有这位前好友克罗斯兰，他机会渺茫。右翼确实还有一位候选人，那就是丹尼斯·希利。是的，丹尼斯·希利。
He's gone around punching people in the face and quoting Emily Dickinson to them. That's not the way to win votes, is it? No, no, no. He's never going to win, but he throws his hat in the ring anyway. So there's the right wing candidates. Then we've got the left wing candidates. So we've got Tony Ben from last time, talking about how much he loves the unions, how much he hates Europe, hates NATO, hates capitalism, all of that. He hasn't been stung on the penis yet by wasp, has he? But that's to come. Not yet. The other candidate on the left is Michael Foote. And he is the sort of sentimental party favorite. He's a brilliant
他到处打人的脸，还给他们引用艾米莉·狄金森的诗。这不是赢得选票的方法，对吧？不，不，不。他永远不会赢，但他还是把帽子扔进了拳击场。所以这是右翼候选人。然后我们有左翼候选人。我们有上次提到的托尼·本，谈论他有多爱工会，有多恨欧洲，恨北约，恨资本主义，所有这些。他还没被黄蜂蜇过阴茎，对吧？但那还在后面。还没。左翼的另一位候选人是迈克尔·富特。他是那种感性的党内宠儿。他是一位出色的
speaker. He's a brilliant essayist. He's a fan of Jonathan Swift and of Byron and all of these kind of 18th century writers. He looks a million years old. Like he looks older than years. Very long white hair, hasn't he? Yeah. And he dresses scruffily and that's something that will come back to bite him in due course. Yes. He wears an ill-advised coat at a... Donkey jacket, I believe. A Rembrandt's Day service. He looked like an out-of-work Navi, I think is my favourite newspaper verdicts on Michael 4. Anyway, he's employment secretary and his job is to suck up to the trade unions and he's going to be the other left-wing candidate. And then that leaves the middle of the party and the candidate at the centre. And this is the great titan of
演说家。他是一位出色的散文家。他是乔纳森·斯威夫特和拜伦以及所有这些18世纪作家的粉丝。他看起来有一百万岁了。就像他看起来比实际年龄大。留着很长的白发，不是吗？是的。而且他穿得很邋遢，这在适当的时候会让他吃苦头。是的。他穿了一件考虑不周的外套……我想是驴皮夹克。在伦勃朗纪念仪式上。他看起来像个失业的码头工人，我想这是我最喜欢的报纸对迈克尔·富特的评价。总之，他是就业大臣，他的工作是讨好工会，他将成为另一位左翼候选人。然后这就留下了党内的中间派和中间候选人。这就是伟大的泰坦
British history, Jim Callahan. And I'm delighted to say we'll be talking a lot more about Jim Callaghan in the next episode. So he's the Sanbrook candidate. Well, I like Dennis Healy as well, to be fair. Callahan just to give you a slight sense, we'll get more into him next time. He's the son of a Royal Navy petty officer from Portsmouth. He left school at 17. He never went to university. He rose through the ranks of the unions and the Labour Party. He's already been Chancellor, Home Secretary and Foreign Secretary, so he's done the hat trick.
英国历史，吉姆·卡拉汉。我很高兴地说，我们将在下一集中更多地谈论吉姆·卡拉汉。所以他是桑布鲁克候选人。嗯，公平地说，我也喜欢丹尼斯·希利。卡拉汉，只是给你一点感觉，我们下次会更多地了解他。他是朴茨茅斯皇家海军士官的儿子。他17岁离开学校。他从未上过大学。他从工会和工党的行列中崛起。他已经担任过财政大臣、内政大臣和外交大臣，所以他完成了帽子戏法。
And so, Domney, if he becomes Prime Minister, he will be the only person in British history who's ever done that, right? Yes, exactly. The Grand Slam! A massive achievement. Massive stakes. His nickname is the keeper of the cloth cap, because he is seen as having this sort of mystical link to the working classes. He's this big bloke. He's avuncular. Everyone always says avuncular by law you have to use that word when you're talking about Jim Calan. He's a bit of a bully,
所以，多米尼克，如果他成为首相，他将是英国历史上唯一做到这一点的人，对吧？是的，完全正确。大满贯！巨大的成就。巨大的赌注。他的绰号是“布帽守护者”，因为他被认为与工人阶级有着某种神秘的联系。他是个大块头。他很和蔼。每个人总是说“和蔼”，法律规定当你谈论吉姆·卡拉汉时必须使用这个词。他有点像个恶霸，
but he's quite sort of solid and reassuring. He has the definitive 1970s kind of glasses. Yeah, I know. It's like Ronnie Barker and Smiley. And he's just the embodiment of 1970s spectacles wearing man. He is. And the other thing, he wears his trousers incredibly high. So he has very, very high-rise trousers. Anyway, he's been plotting for the leadership for more than a decade. And unlike the other people standing, he doesn't give any interviews. He doesn't publish any policies. He doesn't even appear on TV. He says, everybody knows where I stand. He has brilliant connections with the Labour MPs. He thinks, I don't need to really bother with a public campaign. They know where I stand. Let's see if I can do
但他相当稳重且令人安心。他戴着典型的1970年代眼镜。是的，我知道。就像罗尼·巴克和斯迈利。他简直就是1970年代戴眼镜男人的化身。他确实是。还有一件事，他的裤子穿得非常高。所以他的裤子腰线非常、非常高。总之，他已经为领导权密谋了十多年。而且与参选的其他候选人不同，他不接受任何采访。他不发布任何政策。他甚至没有出现在电视上。他说，每个人都知道我的立场。他与工党议员有极好的联系。他想，我真的不需要费心进行公开竞选。他们知道我的立场。让我们看看我能不能做到
this. They have the first ballot on the 25th of March. It's all a bit less dramatic than the Tory business with Margaret Thatcher. It's a sign of just how exhausted and how kind of grey and threadbare they all are, really. Of the also rounds, Crosland comes bottom, he gets 17. Healy gets 31. Jenkins, with his, can't pronounce his ours, he gets 56, which is a really poor showing from him, given that he had been the favourite a few years earlier. It's a sign of how his Euro enthusiasm has hamstrung him.
这一点。他们在3月25日进行了第一轮投票。这比玛格丽特·撒切尔的保守党事务要平淡一些。这标志着他们所有人都已经精疲力竭，而且显得灰暗和破旧。在其他候选人中，克罗斯兰垫底，他获得了17票。希利获得31票。詹金斯，因为他发不好“r”的音，他获得了56票，考虑到他几年前还是热门人选，这对他来说表现非常糟糕。这标志着他的欧洲热情是如何束缚了他的手脚。
So he's going to go off to Europe, actually, and run the Euro. European Commission. On the left, Tony Ben does much worse than you might expect. He gets 37 votes. And that's because a lot of MPs as we discussed last week. They say, you know, he's very polite and he's very courteous and he's charming, but I hate him. They're voting on the personality, not the issues. I think exactly which he would despise.
所以他实际上要去欧洲，管理欧洲委员会。在左翼，托尼·本的表现比你预期的要差得多。他获得了37票。这是因为正如我们上周讨论的那样，很多议员说，你知道，他非常有礼貌，非常有风度，而且很有魅力，但我讨厌他。他们是在投个性票，而不是投议题票。我想这正是他所鄙视的。
And Michael Foote goes way ahead of him on 90. Michael Foote gets 90 with his long white hair and his love of... Yeah, he hasn't it. Yeah, exactly. He's the front runner at this stage. God, I mean, imagine if they elect Michael Furtt's leader of the Labour Party, that would be mad. They'd never do that, surely. Callahan is just behind him on 84, and that's fine, because basically he knows he'll hoover up all the votes of the other right-wing people. Second ballot, they've all put out,
迈克尔·富特以90票遥遥领先。迈克尔·富特凭借他那一头长长的白发和他对……是的，他确实有。是的，完全正确。他在这个阶段是领跑者。天哪，我是说，想象一下如果他们选迈克尔·富特当工党领袖，那会很疯狂。他们肯定永远不会那样做。卡拉汉以84票紧随其后，这很好，因为基本上他知道他会横扫所有其他右翼人士的选票。第二轮投票，他们都退出了，
although also ran's pull out except for Healy. Healy fights on out of just bloody-mindedness and being difficult. Callahan's now narrowly in the lead, 141 to 133 for foot, and the third ballot Healy finally drops out. So Callahan picks up most of his votes. And Callahan on Monday the 5th of April is having lunch on his own in his Commons office. And the chairman of the parliamentary party, Cledwin Hughes comes and knocks on the door and he says, we've got the results.
尽管除了希利之外的其他候选人都退出了。希利因为顽固和难缠而继续战斗。卡拉汉现在以141票对133票微弱领先富特，第三轮投票希利终于退出了。所以卡拉汉获得了他大部分的选票。4月5日星期一，卡拉汉独自在下议院办公室吃午饭。议会党主席克莱德温·休斯敲门进来，他说，我们有结果了。
You have beaten Michael Foote by 176 votes to 137. And Callaghan had this hard man image, but he actually starts crying at this. and he says very slowly and very revealingly I think Prime Minister of Great Britain and I never went to a university and Hughes says to him well you're in good company
你以176票对137票击败了迈克尔·富特。卡拉汉一直有硬汉形象，但他实际上为此哭了起来。他说得非常慢，而且我认为非常具有启发性，大英帝国首相，而我从未上过大学。休斯对他说，嗯，你并不孤单，
the two greatest prime ministers of the century didn't go to university Lloyd George and Churchill and then Callaghan's aides come in to congratulate him and again he harps on the same theme he says to one of them there are many cleverer people than me in the Labour Party but they're there and I'm here You can see the chip on his shoulder.
本世纪最伟大的两位首相都没有上过大学，劳合·乔治和丘吉尔。然后卡拉汉的助手们进来祝贺他，他再次强调了同样的主题，他对其中一个人说，工党里有很多人比我聪明，但他们在那儿，而我在这儿。你可以看出他心中的不满。
Anyway, he then goes and addresses all the Labour MPs. He gives them a nice unity speech. He says, you know, clean slate after all the fighting of the Wilson years. And then he gets in the car to take him to Buckingham Palace. And at night, he addresses the British people for the first time as Prime Minister. And his aides prepared him a speech. But interestingly, he tweaked it because he wanted to emphasise the theme of restoring traditional values. And he says, you know, priority is to fight inflation.
总之，他随后去向所有工党议员发表讲话。他给了他们一个很好的团结演讲。他说，你知道，在威尔逊时代的各种争斗之后，我们要重新开始。然后他上了车，前往白金汉宫。晚上，他第一次以首相身份向英国人民发表讲话。他的助手为他准备了一份演讲稿。但有趣的是，他调整了它，因为他想强调恢复传统价值观的主题。他说，你知道，首要任务是打击通货膨胀。
We're going to stop borrowing so much money. we stop going deeper and deeper into debt. No one owes Britain a living, he says. I mean, this is the kind of speech that Mrs. Satcha could have given. You're not wrong, because if you look at the rest of it, we've got to stop appeasing the greedy and graspy and selfish. He wants an end to vandalism and violence. The family is at the heart of the battle for our national survival.
我们要停止借那么多钱。我们停止越陷越深。他说，没有人欠英国什么。我是说，这是撒切尔夫人可能会发表的那种演讲。你没说错，因为如果你看看剩下的部分，我们必须停止安抚那些贪婪、攫取和自私的人。他想要结束破坏和暴力。家庭是我们国家生存之战的核心。
Parents should stand firm in defence of old-fashioned morality, and above all, he wants a national effort to uphold our values and our standards. And Tom, this is top Sanbrook Daily Mail column bingo, isn't it? And it's a sign that Callaghan is going to be a very different kind of prime minister from Harold Wilson. So you might think everything is looking great for Britain and for big gym. But no, on his first full day as prime minister, one of his junior ministers called Brian O'Malley died after brain surgery and hospital. on his second day as Prime Minister, another Labour MP, a disgraced Labour MP called, this is very hard to explain in one sentence, but basically a disgraced Labour MP called John Stonehouse,
父母应该坚定地捍卫老派道德，最重要的是，他想要一场全国性的努力来维护我们的价值观和标准。汤姆，这是桑布鲁克《每日邮报》专栏的顶级宾果游戏，不是吗？这标志着卡拉汉将成为与哈罗德·威尔逊截然不同的首相。所以你可能认为英国和大个子吉姆的一切看起来都很棒。但没有，在他担任首相的第一个完整日子里，他的一位初级大臣布莱恩·奥马利在医院接受脑部手术后去世了。在他担任首相的第二天，另一位工党议员，一位名誉扫地的工党议员叫，这很难用一句话解释，但基本上是一位名誉扫地的工党议员叫约翰·斯通豪斯，
who had faked his own death on a beach in Miami and then turned up in Melbourne and was arrested as a fraudster. He quit the party, he's returned to British politics, he quits the party, and he says there should be an immediate general election. So now Callahan has no majority at all. after just a couple of days. He's got 314 seats. All the others put together have got 316 seats. And to survive, he has to rely on the votes of two Northern Irish nationalist MPs
他在迈阿密的海滩上伪造了自己的死亡，然后出现在墨尔本，并以欺诈罪被捕。他退出了该党，他回到了英国政坛，他退出了该党，他说应该立即举行大选。所以现在卡拉汉根本没有多数席位。仅仅几天之后。他有314个席位。所有其他人加起来有316个席位。为了生存，他必须依靠两名北爱尔兰民族主义议员的选票，
who Jerry Fitt and Frank McGuire. So that's pretty bad. He's got no majority. And then just a few days after that, the governor of the Bank of England comes to see him and says, I've got terrible news. I've got really, really, really bad news. The pound is collapsing once again. we are running out of money
杰里·菲特和弗兰克·麦奎尔。所以这很糟糕。他没有多数席位。就在那几天之后，英格兰银行行长来见他，说，我有可怕的消息。我有非常、非常、非常糟糕的消息。英镑再次崩溃。我们的钱快用完了。
Britain is staring into the abyss of bankruptcy and it seems that Jim Callahan's premiership is doomed before it has even properly begun what will Dominic's great hero do you can find out in the thrilling climax of this epic series and on that thrilling climax we will also be welcoming
英国正凝视着破产的深渊，看起来吉姆·卡拉汉的首相任期在还没真正开始之前就已经注定失败了。多米尼克的伟大英雄会做什么？你可以在这个史诗系列激动人心的高潮中找到答案，在这个激动人心的高潮中，我们也将欢迎
onto the rest of history for the first time the sex pistols So Rest Is History Club members can hear that episode right now and to join them. Of course you know what we've got to do. Head to the Restis History.com. If not, you just have to wait. But we will be back with the Sex Pistols. Goodbye.
第一次来到“历史其余部分”的性手枪乐队。所以“历史其余部分”俱乐部的成员现在就可以听到那一集，并加入他们。当然，你知道我们必须做什么。前往RestisHistory.com。如果没有，你就只能等了。但我们会带着性手枪乐队回来。再见。
Goodbye. We have an absolutely thrilling announcement to make. Yes, Tom. This is probably the most thrilling announcement we've ever made on The Rest Is History because we have a very special bespoke Rest is History T-shirt available to celebrate our new series about Britain in the 1970s.
再见。我们有一个绝对激动人心的公告要宣布。是的，汤姆。这可能是我们在《历史其余部分》中发布过的最激动人心的公告，因为我们有一件非常特别的定制版《历史其余部分》T恤，以庆祝我们关于1970年代英国的新系列。
These were great years. Crazy scenes, of course, behind the door number 10. Britain had to go, I believe the technical term is cap in hand to the International Monetary Fund for a record bailout. And of course, Tony Benn was funding factories that made both car radiators and orange juice. And what you're probably thinking, Tom, is how can I get a T-shirt that somehow captures the same,
这些是伟大的岁月。当然，唐宁街10号门后有疯狂的场景。我相信技术术语是“卑躬屈膝”地向国际货币基金组织寻求创纪录的救助。当然，托尼·本当时正在资助既生产汽车散热器又生产橙汁的工厂。你可能在想，汤姆，我怎样才能得到一件能以某种方式捕捉到同样
spirit of those tremendous years. So what we have done is to commission Graham Johnson, who is one of our beloved Athelstands, to come back with another stunning design. And this time, and this is so brilliant, must be the only T-shirt ever, to feature the heads of Edward Heath, Margaret Thatcher, Harold Wilson and James Callaghan. And if you're not British, I mean, What's wrong with you? This will be the most exclusive, the most exclusive t-shirt design ever. Imagine walking the streets of Peoria with your James Callahan T-shirt. Unmissible.
那些伟大岁月精神的T恤呢？所以我们所做的是委托我们敬爱的阿塞尔斯坦人之一格雷厄姆·约翰逊带回另一个令人惊叹的设计。这一次，这太棒了，一定是唯一一件印有爱德华·希思、玛格丽特·撒切尔、哈罗德·威尔逊和詹姆斯·卡拉汉头像的T恤。如果你不是英国人，我是说，你怎么了？这将是有史以来最独特、最独特的T恤设计。想象一下穿着你的詹姆斯·卡拉汉T恤走在皮奥里亚的街头。不可错过。
So Dominic, here's the question. How can people go about getting their hands on one of these unbelievable items? Just head to the rest is history.com and go to our merch page. And for our wonderful club members, do keep an eye out for this week's newsletter. which will include a special discount for friends for the show and an even more exciting discount for our ever-beloved Athelstands and you can use this code on all the rest is history merch. Now, if you're not yet a member of the show,
所以多米尼克，问题来了。人们怎样才能买到这些令人难以置信的商品之一呢？只需前往RestisHistory.com并进入我们的商品页面。对于我们出色的俱乐部成员，请留意本周的时事通讯，其中将包括为节目朋友提供的特别折扣，以及为我们永远敬爱的阿塞尔斯坦人提供的更令人兴奋的折扣，你可以在所有《历史其余部分》商品上使用此代码。现在，如果你还不是该节目的会员，
you're probably thinking, I really want one of these t-shirts, I'm desperate for a discount, I'm missing out on all the unbelievable benefits that you get through club membership. Well, here's the thing. Now is the time to sign up. You can go.
你可能在想，我真的很想要其中一件T恤，我渴望折扣，我错过了通过俱乐部会员资格获得的所有令人难以置信的好处。嗯，事情是这样的。现在是注册的时候了。你可以去。
just as Britain went to the International Monetary Fund. Cap in hand. Cap in hand. Go to the restishistory.com to sign up and you will get, I mean, even more largesse than Britain got from the IMF in 1976. It'll be absolutely brilliant. So please go to the restishistory.com and sign up. You'll get all the discounts. You can buy your merch.
就像英国去国际货币基金组织一样。卑躬屈膝。卑躬屈膝。前往RestisHistory.com注册，你将获得，我是说，比英国在1976年从国际货币基金组织获得的还要多的慷慨。那绝对会很棒。所以请前往RestisHistory.com并注册。你将获得所有折扣。你可以购买你的商品。
You can get all the tremendous benefits that you get from being a member and you'll never ever be happier and you will never ever regret it. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以获得作为会员所获得的所有巨大好处，你将永远、永远不会更快乐，也永远、永远不会后悔。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。